Willkommen zu Mobile-Max, Ausgabe Nummer 15. Immer noch ohne Jingle. 15.
Aber dafür diesmal mit Thema.
Und mit Vorstellungen. Ich bin Tim.
Ich bin Dennis.
Und da sind wir wieder, wir drei, wir Schlingel. Wir, die wir Prognosen wagen, um danach komplett auf die Nase zu fallen. Ich zum Beispiel.
Wir Glaskugelblicker.
Epic Fail sagt man heute.
Was hab ich gesagt? Geht gar nicht irgendwie.
Eyebrick wär kompletter Schwachsinn. Quasi.
Darüber braucht man gar nicht zu reden, dass man das irgendwie aus einem Teil schnitzt.
Das geht gar nicht.
Und dann kommt dieser Sucker, dieser...
Der Brite.
Genau. Der Brite kommt und sagt, ich wollte, dass das alles ganz hübsch ist und schön. Naja, und jetzt ist es alles ganz hübsch und schön.
Zu deiner Ehrenrettung. Du hattest gesagt auch, dass du darauf hoffst, dass die stabiler sind und in sich geschlossener, weil sie aus einem Stück sind.
Und er hat gesagt, dass dieses mit den schwitzenden Händen und so, diese Oberfläche, dass alles scheiße ist, und jetzt ist das Aluminium ja wirklich oben.
Ja, ich muss sagen, ich hab nicht wirklich eine Ahnung von solchen Produktionsprozessen. Ich bin halt davon ausgegangen, dass man das wie das R gebaut ist, dass das sozusagen auch ohne Fräsen möglich ist. Nicht, dass ich da mich wirklich viel mit beschäftigt hätte, aber dass das sozusagen jetzt ein einziger Alu, ein einziges Alu-Gerät ist, das war ja mein erklärter Wunsch. Vor allem die Oberfläche. Und das scheint ja nun wirklich so weit zu sein. Das heißt, dieses Problem der MacBook Pros und der Powerbooks zuvor, was ich immer hatte, dass man eben dieses Plastik durchschwitzt, sollte der Vergangenheit angehören.
Wie findet ihr denn überhaupt die neuen MacBooks?
Also ja, ich denke, das ist ein ganz großer Wurf. Also da haben sie jetzt endlich etwas abgeworfen, was einfach total überfällig war. Und sie haben wirklich viel drüber nachgedacht. Und dass das so lange gedauert hat, das denke ich ist jetzt auch klar warum. Weil sie erstmal die Produktionskapazitäten schaffen mussten, um diesen aufwendigen Gehäuseherstellungsprozess herzubekommen. Also diese Uni-Body-Enclosure-Technik, die sie da jetzt auch nochmal im Detail vorgestellt haben, das ist dann wahrscheinlich der Brick, was weiß ich.
Na klar, es kommt aus einem Stück.
Kommt aus einem Stück und das ist natürlich großartig. Ich meine, ich hab das MacBook Air, meine Freundin hat das ja, und das ist einfach ein super Teil. Diese Stabilität, also diese Verwindungssteifheit vor allem, Stabilität trifft es irgendwie nicht so richtig. Dass das Ding einfach überhaupt nicht mehr flext, zumindest nicht mehr merklich flext. Wenn du so deinen MacBook oder Powerbook oder was auch immer MacBook Pro in die Hand nimmst, links und rechts fasst und dann so ein bisschen die Hände gegeneinander verdrehst, da ist einfach Torsion im Spiel sofort. Es knarzt und so. Das ist zwar schon stabil, aber man merkt einfach, es bewegt sich. Und das, denke ich mal, ich hab jetzt so ein neues Teil noch nicht in der Hand gehabt. Ich denke, ihr dürftet auch noch keinen Erfolg gehabt haben, aber hier beim Apple Store in Toronto hatten sie noch keine.
Also ich bin heute extra zum Alex gefahren, in Zalexia hatten sie auch noch keine. Da haben sie gesagt, irgendwas von wegen in zwei Wochen vielleicht.
Auch beim Media Markt oder was?
Beim Media Markt da drinnen, ja. Da ist ja so ein Apple-Händler oben drin, so ein Spezieller. Ja, ich dachte vielleicht, das ist das, was dem Apple Store am nächsten kommt. Ich glaube nicht. Naja, das ist ja so Apple Store in Store oder irgendwie sowas.
Ja, das ist schon von Apple organisiert. Das ist schon von Apple organisiert.
Irgendwie gehört das nicht so richtig dazu. Ansonsten, ich habe ja gesagt, nee, Nvidia glaube ich nicht dran. Jetzt ist es Nvidia. Also damit habe ich daneben gelegen.
Da hatte ich so recht keinen Überblick. Das macht natürlich schon schwer Sinn. Und da sie ja nun bei den Prozessoren nicht wirklich zugelegt haben, ist das natürlich eigentlich die wirkliche Performance-Meldung. Und ich finde mehrere Sachen daran sehr interessant an diesem Nvidia-Chipset. Also erstmal, dass die überhaupt welche bauen. Also dass die solche kompletten Chipsets bauen, die man dann auch in Laptops einsetzen kann.
Auf dem Business halt auch.
Chipsets.
Ist das so, dass man wirklich mit einem Chip einen kompletten Rechner, mit Grafikkarte, mit so einer Hochleistungs-Grafikkarte onboard, gibt es das schon länger von denen?
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es auf einem Chip ist. Das ist aber der Vorteil gegenüber Intel, die da wohl zwei Chips haben, aber Intel hat schon länger Chipsets für die CPUs im Angebot. Das ist also nichts Neues.
Gut, aber das ist dann zumindest die letzte Entwicklung. Offensichtlich haben sie da ordentlich Performance reingesteckt. Wenn ich das richtig zusammenfasse, hat dieser 9400M, also der, der auf dem Chipset mit drauf ist, 16 Cores.
Genau.
Der hat irgendwie 16 Cores und das ist halt auch diese CUDA-Technik, also für die kommende Technologie OpenCL, Snow Leopard, ideale Voraussetzungen. Das ist genau die Ressource, die sich mit OpenCL künftig unter Mac OS X sehr leicht nutzen lässt. Beziehungsweise auch jetzt schon genutzt wird, wie zum Beispiel von der Creative Suite CS4. Die hat ja auch Hardware-Beschleunigung mit drin. Und die nutzen meines Wissens eben auch diese Technik.
Zur CUDA kann ich gleich noch kurz was erzählen. Und zwar habe ich gehört in unserem Chat-System hier, dass die Jungs von... Was war das? Mplay oder VLC? Nee, Quatsch! Die H264 Jungs, also X264, das ist ja so der H.264-Codec, ich glaube es heißt X264. Und die haben zusammen mit den NVIDIA-Entwicklern oder Technikern wie auch immer versucht, den H.264-Codec mit diesem CUDA zu implementieren. Und sie haben es auch mit deren Hilfe nicht geschafft, denen ordentlich schnell hinzukriegen. Also wir sehen ja auch erst so ein bisschen den Anfang der Entwicklung, bis man es wirklich schneller hinkriegt als mit der CPU, dauert es noch eine Weile. Jedenfalls bestimmte Jobs. Und H264 ist anscheinend noch nicht so weit. Also ein bisschen komplexer als Bildbearbeitung, weil es ja halt schon Video-Encoding ist, wahrscheinlich noch mal was anderes. Encoding.
Aber das Decoding läuft schon mit Hardware-Unterstützung oder nicht?
Ja, meistens ja bei diesen, so wie X264, die müssen ihren Source ja schon sehr generisch halten. Und meistens sind die ganz normal softwaremäßig ohne Hardware-Unterstützung. Also auch hier VLC und hier M-Player und so, ich glaub, so richtig, die Hardware gehen hier nicht ran. Das ist schon anders als wenn du QuickTime benutzt, da kriegst du glaub ich da schon mehr von ab.
Ja eben, ich denke bei Mac OS X hast du diese Hardware-Beschleunigung.
Ja, da müssen wir mal gucken, ob man die dann auch bei H264-Encoding kriegt.
Das wird sich zeigen, ich denke mal, das ist wahrscheinlich auch einer der Gründe, warum sie QuickTime neu schreiben. Also das QuickTime X, da hab ich ehrlich gesagt hohe Erwartungen genau da dran, dass sie also die OpenCL-Geschichte benutzen, um alle ihre Codecs, sei es Encoding oder Decoding, zu beschleunigen. Aber da sind wir wieder im klassischen wissen wir eigentlich nicht so genauen Bereich, da sollte man nicht so viel rumlatschen.
Also irgendeine Firma hat jetzt, irgendeine russische Firma hat eine Software zum Knacken von WPA und WPA2-Passwort dran geschrieben und die hat GPU-Beschleunigung und soll wohl dadurch um einiges schneller werden als bei CPU-Beschleunigung. Also das hängt offensichtlich sehr schnell.
Zwei, drei Tage auf Heise und die können es natürlich prima beschleunigen, weil Passwortknacken kann man natürlich super parallelisieren.
Für Krypto ist sowas ja auch optimal.
100-fache Geschwindigkeit, wenn ich das hier richtig sehe.
Überrascht mich überhaupt nicht. Das ist eigentlich das, wofür es auch wunderbar taugt.
Alles mit den zwei Grafikkarten ist ein bisschen lustig im MacBook Pro. Oder? Was haltet ihr denn davon? So dieses, wenn ich ein Spiel spielen will, muss ich mich erst ausloggen? Das ist ein bisschen doof, finde ich. Irgendwie kriegt das noch so nichts ganz und nicht zahlen.
Das ist die Frage, was dein Default ist. Du kannst ja auch die ganze Zeit das High-End im Default halten, aber dann schluckt er halt mehr Strom.
Klar, aber irgendwie klingt das doch so ein bisschen so, ja, wir wollten kleinere Akkus einbauen, haben aber nicht ganz die Stromersparnis rausgekriegt, die wir wollten, und haben darum zwei Grafikkarten eingebaut. Oder geht das nicht? Kann man die einfach nicht rausnehmen aus diesem Chipsatz? Ist der Chipsatz auch...
Der Chipsatz besteht zu 70% da draußen. Genau, das ist einfach ein Chip und der besteht zu 70%. Das war ja auch in dieser Präsentation, wo du das erwähnt hast. Der besteht zu 70% aus dieser Grafikkarte. Das ist einfach ein Teil davon. Und sie haben sich jetzt von der Architektur für diesen Chipsatz entschlossen. Und von daher ist der MacBook Pro einfach mit drin. Da das dann aber nicht ausreicht als Performance, haben sie zusätzlich noch einen extra Grafikstein eingebaut. Genau, der dann locker nochmal doppelt so schnell ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Ihr habt ja auch den Stream gesehen, oder? Also die Key-Mode als Video.
Ich find ja Jonathan Yves so lustig, der macht so ein bisschen so immer den verrückten Professor. Ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl.
Verrückter Professor?
Naja, wie er mal so ein bisschen gelacht hat, als er den Prozess vorgestellt hat, weil er sich so gefreut hat, wie toll der ist und niemand außer ihm lachen konnte, weil natürlich niemand die Komplexität dieses neuen Alu-Prozesses versteht. Das find ich sehr lustig.
Ich würd sagen, der ist auf jeden Fall sehr angetan und sehr berührt von seinem eigenen Design. Das zeichnet ihn ja auch aus.
Offensichtlich.
Ja, war überhaupt interessant zu sehen, wie viele Führungspersonal für die doch relativ kleine Präsentationen zum Einsatz kamen. Na, das erste Mal überhaupt Tim Cook? Sonst ist der Schiller häufig da, aber dieses Mal war eben Tim Cook da.
Der macht seinen Job ganz gut.
Ja, aber es war sicherlich auch so ein klares Statement in die Richtung mit, guck mal, wir haben noch mehr Leute als nur Steve Jobs. Und die können auch was, und die sind auch wichtig, und die können auch irgendwie reden halten, und dann sind die doof.
Ja, zum Ende, das ist ja dann im Livestream leider nicht mehr gekommen, aber zum Ende bei dem Q&A ging es ja auch nochmal um den Gesintheitszustand von Steve Jobs. Da wurde ja nochmal sein Puls an die Bühne, an die Leinwand geworfen.
Ja, sie versuchen halt diese Diskussion zu beenden. Das wird auch mal Zeit. Die führen wir jetzt nicht. Bleiben wir lieber nochmal bei diesen Chipset- und Grafikkarten. Also mit dem Umschalten, warum es nötig ist, dass man sich auslockt, um zwischen der einen Karte und der anderen hinterherzuschalten, ist mir nicht so ganz klar. Kann aber einfach eine rein ästhetische Geschichte sein, dass ihr eben nicht ohne Ka-Flash, Ka-Zuckel und Ka-Wumms in der Lage sind, dahin und herzuschalten? Weiß ich nicht. Letztlich ist es ja so, wenn du dich auslockst, beendest du den Windows-Server und der Windows-Server ist derjenige, der im Wesentlichen mit dem Quad-Subsystem und damit eben auch mit der Grafikkarte kommuniziert. Das hat auch sicherlich was mit dem Freilassen von Ressourcen zu tun. Die sind ja extrem eng verflochten. So, die Grafikkarte und der Quad-Slayer. Und das mag ein Grund sein, dass sie das jetzt zumindest vorerst mal so machen müssen. Vielleicht finden sie ja zukünftig einen Weg, da sozusagen einen cleanen Übergang zu machen. I don't know. Letzten Endes werden sich die Leute wahrscheinlich sowieso nicht permanent von der einen Grafikkarte auf die andere Grafikkarte umentscheiden.
Wahrscheinlich wird sich nach einer Weile rausstellen, dass 80% der MacBook-Probener sowieso immer mit der internen Grafik arbeiten. Also ich kann mir das bei mir gut vorstellen.
Ich denke, es gibt die Leute, die wollen einfach die volle Leistung haben, sind aber trotzdem sehr mobil und für die ist einfach Akku wichtiger. Und wenn sie dann mal wirklich die Performance brauchen, schalten sie um. Und dann gibt es die Leute, die eigentlich dieses Teil eher zum Arbeitsplatz schleppen oder es sowieso eigentlich als ihren Hauptrechner auf dem Desk verwenden und die haben dann sowieso immer Strom dran und dann ist das mit dem Akku auch nicht so wichtig.
Coolsten wäre es schon, dass umgeschaltet wird und ich mache Strom ran und automatisch nimmt er die große Karte.
Ja, dann wärs cool, klar, aber so bis dahin finde ich halt, ist das so ein bisschen so naja, nicht Fisch, nicht Fleisch. Irgendwie wär da noch ein bisschen was praktisch.
Na ja, abwarten.
Bei Windows musst du wahrscheinlich booten.
Also ich hab mal irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei einem dieser Netbooks gibt's von Asus, gibt's einen relativ, was ist das von Asus? Schönes Halbwissen, gibt's ein schönes Video im Netz. Auf jeden Fall auch zwei Grafikkarten, genau das gleiche Prinzip, eine separate Parade und eine On-Board-Grafikkarte. Und die haben da eine Taste, mit der man umschalten kann. Und da passiert einfach, dass es so, klack, da geht kurz das Display aus, geht wieder an und da ist ein Bildschirmen halt angeblich auf der neuen Grafikkarte. Also da sollte Apple noch ein bisschen dazulernen.
Unter welchem Betriebssystem?
Ich glaube, das war unter Linux. Tja, aber ich lehne mich jetzt gerade aus dem Fenster. Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass es schon jetzt eigentlich geht, wenn man irgendeine Tastenkombination gedrückt hält. Das ist bloß so, was weiß ich was, wenn man dann Apple Alt-Ctrl beim Klicken des Grafikkartenwechsels hält, dass es aber wahrscheinlich in einigen Programme damit Probleme haben werden, mit dem Grafikkartenwechsel. Also gerade Programme, die eben direkt die Grafikkarte ansprechen. Also wenn du Photoshop CS4 noch am Laufen hast, was dann vielleicht eine Berechnung macht, gerade auf der Grafikkarte, ist das bestimmt nicht sonderlich erfreut darüber, wenn du mit dem Grafikkartenwechsel...
Was ich eben gerade meinte, du hast halt die Programme laufen, um die einzige Möglichkeit sicherzustellen, dass keine Programme laufen und dass die Programme nicht mit ihrem eigenen Ressourcenmanagement durcheinander kommen, weil sie irgendwelche Register, Bufferblöcke, Cues, was weiß ich verwalten gerade, ist einfach ausloggen. Und das ist eine relativ entspannte Methode. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie das so ohne weiteres hätten anders machen können. Dieses On-the-Fly, klar, das ist das, was man haben will, aber ich denke, das geht einfach an den Realitäten der Technologie vorbei. Wird man sehen müssen. Auf jeden Fall denke ich nicht, dass das jetzt eines der wichtigsten Punkte ist. Wenn man sich über solche Sachen unterhält, dann kann man wieder erstmal eigentlich nicht...
Aber habt ihr gesehen, man kann jetzt endlich den Deckel abmachen und die Festplatte austauschen.
Aber man muss nach wie vor rumschrauben, um an den RAM ranzukommen.
Ja, aber RAM wechselst du nicht so häufig wie deine Festplatte.
Ja, es ist nicht so, dass du deinen RAM mal rausnimmst und durch ein anderes RAM ersetzt. Sondern du fuchst da halt irgendwann mal in deinem Leben mal mehr hinzu. Und dann hast du halt RAM. Und dafür selbst Schrauben zu lösen, ist okay.
Also ich fand da die Lösung beim MacBook schöner, wo man an beides problemlos ankommt.
Aber habt ihr gesehen, dass das Limit auch immer noch bei 4 GB...
Es ist besser geworden. Es ist viel besser geworden.
Aber sie schreiben es aber erst.
Ich hab gesehen, dass das nicht unbedingt so ist, sondern dass Apple sagt, dass es... Ja, aber das machen sie immer. Das haben sie auch schon früher bei ihren Macintoshes gemacht, die theoretisch von der System-Architektur mehr RAM verkraftet haben und als diese Steine dann auch wirklich auf dem Markt verfügbar waren. Beziehungsweise auch selbst... Ich hoffe, dass die mehr Konzepte haben... .kannst du sie reinbauen, dann hattest du auch mehr RAM.
Das will man schon haben heutzutage, oder?
Das war immer so. Soweit ich... Ich hab mir keine genauen Tech-Specs durchgelesen von den Chipsets. Aber was ich so wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass sie wohl schon 8GB können. Nur, dass derzeit 8GB so dermaßen sinnlos teuer wäre dafür, dass Apple das selber nicht im Angebot hat. Und es war halt schon immer so, dass wenn Apple selber dieses Upgrade nicht anbietet, dass sie dann auch nicht draufschreiben, dass es geht.
Aber zur Zeit ist doch Speicher gerade...
Weil, wenn es ginge, würden sie es ja anbieten. Das ist nicht tun, gibt es das nicht. Aber technisch wird es möglich sein.
Na ja, weiß ich nicht. Also für meins irgendwie 4GB...
DDR3? DDR2. Aber das ist jetzt DDR3. Und ich weiß nicht genau, wie die Preise gerade sind. Ich hab nur gehört, sie wären irgendwie ridiculously high. Also du zahlst halt einfach derzeit noch eine große Strafgebühr. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man im einem Jahr in der Lage ist, die ganze Karte rauszunehmen und durch ein 8 GB-Riegel zu ersetzen. Aber das müsstest du dann wahrscheinlich auch tun.
Achso, das gibt's ja in einem Jahr.
Ob wir erst mal 4 GB auf einem Timb kriegen?
Ja, wir wissen's mal wieder nicht genau. Aber meine Vermutung ist, das MacBook Pro kann mehr.
Aber ich sag euch das hier und zwar... Aber ich weiß ja auch schon mal nicht so schlecht, ob das MacBook 4 GB macht. Die Bröse kosten hier 2 GB Module so um die 70 Euro. Und 4 GB Module... Eins kostet hier 150, eins kostet 200 Euro.
Also...
Und 8 GB...
4 GB Modul? Na, 4 GB würden ja schon reichen.
Stimmt ja.
Da bräuchte man ja zwei von, dann hätte man ja 8 GB.
Obwohl, stopp, ich muss es zurückziehen. Die 4 GB werden hier als zwei Einzelmodule verkauft, die schummeln also. Also ok, muss man noch abwarten, bis 4 GB Module rauskommen. Ok, deswegen hat Apple das alles angegeben.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Ja, also... Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal, wo wir gerade bei Grafikkarten waren, als nächste Technologie. Ich glaube, die größte Änderung, die wir jetzt hier haben, ist halt ein weiterer Generationssprung mit dem Display-Port. Das ist wirklich mal wieder so ein Break. Nachdem ja noch nicht mal alle anderen mit DVI und so weiter nachgezogen sind, sondern irgendwie immer noch bei VGA stecken geblieben sind, geht Apple einen Schritt weiter und sagt, DVI gibt's nicht mehr. Sondern wir machen jetzt nur noch Display-Port und bringen auch noch einen neuen Stecker. Den es so derzeit zumindest in der Wikipedia noch nicht dokumentiert gibt. Allerdings, hast du das schon bestätigt gesehen, dass das ein Standard ist?
Ja, aber ich hab auch die Wikiseite zum Display-Port gelesen.
Ja, da steht Link auf Mini-Display-Port und da steht drin ist ein Stecker, den nur Apple verwendet. Und mehr steht da nicht. Da steht nicht, dass das im Weser-Standard drin ist. Ja gut, ich denke nicht, dass sie jetzt wirklich mit einem Stecker losmarschieren, den sie sich selber ausgedacht haben.
Na doch, mit diesem ADC...
Meines Wissens haben sie ganz früher mal gemacht.
Doch, doch, doch.
Genau, Apple-Display-Connector.
Der ist aber auch nicht von Apple, das war auch ein Weser-Standard. Den haben sie bloß so genannt.
Nee, da ging sogar ADB drüber und sowas. Ich glaube, das war ein Apple-eignes Ding.
Nee, da ging kein ADB drüber, da ging ein USB drüber.
Nee, da ging noch, da ging noch, ähm, da ging noch. Sprechen wir jetzt von was anderem? Also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, ein 14 Zoll-Monitor an einem Performer 660, über den definitiv noch ADB ging.
Nee, über den Monitor-Stecker ging damals kein ADB.
Doch, doch, doch. 100%ig. Das war das Apple 14 Zoll Display, oder wie das hieß.
Ah, V-Display. Bei welchem Computer?
Das war ein Power Mac 6100. Und das war ein 14 Zoll, also ich glaube 640 x 480, wirklich eine ganz geringe Auflösung, aber mit Boxen drin und Mikrofon drin, SVGA-Eingang, nicht SVGA hier, Super Video-Eingang und da ging auch noch ADB drüber.
Also ich hab hier gerade mit einer Rekuperie den Apple Display-Connector, da steht DVI, USB und Power.
Nee, ADC ist ein bisschen neuer, das stimmt schon. Das war richtig lange her.
Du darfst den Link dann gerne für die Linksammlung rausholen. Ja, aber das Schöne ist an, also ja, weiß nicht, also DisplayPort hat ja aber einen Vor-
und Nachverteilung.
Also ich find's natürlich als El Chippo-Customer, sag ich mal, erstmal ganz gut, weil der Stecker ist hier leichter als immer diesen DVI-Stecker da so, da musst du genau treffen, bis der reingeht, weil ich hab hier auch meinen Laptop an so einem 23 Zoll Cinema Display. Und dann hast du halt aber auch nur Bild und hast keinen Ton. Und bei dem Display-Port ist es ein kleiner einfacher Stecker, da kannst du auch im Dunkeln irgendwie süß das Loch stoppst irgendwie rein, wobei ich glaube, der ist nicht verdrehsicher, muss schon richtig rum sein, ne? Aber auf jeden Fall kommt auch gleich Audio mit irgendwie da drüber raus. Und das neue Apple-Display hat ja auch irgendwie Lautsprecher unten an der Unterseite. Und das ist natürlich für den normalsterblichen User erstmal toll, aber wie Tim vorhin schon erzählt hat, gibt's wohl keinen Composite-Ausgang mehr. Ich weiß gar nicht, liegt überhaupt noch ein Adapter dann bei?
Nicht nur kein Composite, auch kein S-Video. Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Video-Ausgang mehr. Und es gibt auch keinen Adapter, der das macht. Und es gibt auch keine Nennung von S-Video und Composite auf den Tech-Specs, was sie immer genannt haben, wenn das geht. Und ich vermute einfach mal, diese Funktionalität existiert jetzt nicht mehr.
Aber vielleicht müssen VJs einfach nur aufschreien.
VJs werden aufschreien, glaube ich. Ja, aber die VJs haben auch keine Kontrolle darüber, dass überall, wo sie auftreten Video-Beamer und Video-Mischpulte und Video und Video, das ist einfach der Standard. Es gibt keinen digitalen Video-Standard. Video ist einfach Video und da gehst du mit S-Video raus und dann hast du da deine Monitore dran und deine Videomixer und über VGA und DVI kannst du gar nichts erreichen. Das werden sie wahrscheinlich auch tun, weil sie einfach mit diesem Gerät nicht mehr auftreten können. Das heißt, die einzige Möglichkeit, die sie jetzt haben, ist, dass sie eine Grafikkarte in den Express-Card-Slot reinstecken, wo noch mal das Video rauskommt. Das ist dann vielleicht so die Option, aber da ist dann wieder die Frage, was bedeutet das für die Performance, wenn du nicht die eingebaute Grafikkarte benutzt? Das sind dann auch noch mal zusätzliche Kosten, die quasi mit vollen Gerätepreisen eingepreist werden müssen. Und ich glaube, die werden sich da nicht besonders darüber freuen. Auch dieser Stecker selber, ich meine, dieser Displayport-Stecker, das muss man mal gucken, aber so vom Anschauen her hat der so in etwa die Griffigkeit von so einem Mini-DVI-Stecker. Und ein Mini-DVI-Stecker verglichen mit dem DVI-Stecker ist natürlich zwergisch. Ich meine, da weißt du jetzt schon, was passiert, wenn du daran ziehst. Dann geht das Ding ab. So ein DVI-Adapter, Hammer, den schraubst du da mit zwei fetten Schrauben in deinen Computer rein und dann hast du da eine 1A-Zugentlastung. Das ist einfach perfekt. Jeder, der mal so Präsentation gehalten hat, wo dann so dicke 10 Meter lange, schwere VGA-Kabel angetrullert kommen, wird sich freuen, so einen Adapter an seinem Gerät dran zu haben.
Ich halte es wie mit dem Strom, weil mir lieber, dass der Kabel rauszieht, als dass mein Rechner runterreißt.
Ja, also das ist halt so eine Frage. Ich meine, sie sind mit dem Argument jetzt auf DisplayPort gegangen, dass es halt höhere Auflösungen unterstützt und sozusagen zukunftskompatibler ist als HDMI. Das ist zumindest etwas, was Steve Jobs gesagt hat. Das stimmt allerdings, wenn ich das richtig recherchiert habe. Zumindest derzeit so noch nicht. Es gibt durchaus ein HDMI. Es gibt HDMI 1.3 und HDMI 1.3 unterstützt 2.560 x 1.600.
Also auflösungsmäßig ist das das gleiche.
Genau. So, bloß offensichtlich wollen sie auch den nächsten Schritt gehen und noch höhere Auflösungen fahren, beziehungsweise noch größere Bildschirme damit treiben, was ja durchaus zu begrüßen ist. Und aus irgendwelchen Gründen sehen sie da halt den Displayport vorne. Technisch ist es ganz interessant, weil die Funktionsweise ist ganz anders. Also bei DVI hast du den eigentlichen Videodata-Kanal und die Clocks sind separat. Und dadurch sind auch die Auflösungen beschränkt und vor allem auch in Abhängigkeit zur Kabellänge beschränkt. Das DisplayPort-System arbeitet mit etwas, was sie irgendwie Micro- oder Mini-Packets nennen. Das heißt, tatsächlich ist es mehr so wie IP. Die schicken da wirklich Datenpakete raus. Was den Vorteil hat, ist, dass du das eben erstens, das Data und Clock ist sozusagen dasselbe. Das Ding clockt sich selber, das heißt es skaliert besser nach oben weg. Und das andere ist, dass du beliebig Metadata dazwischen fügen kannst. So ist also auch der Rückkanal klar. Du kannst auch USB und auch so was wie Mikrofone und Kameras über HDMI machen. Und das ist jetzt schon mal die erste Frage, die ich habe, wo ich noch keine Antwort darauf gefunden habe. Dieses neue Display kommt ja mit so einem Triple-Stecker, wo USB dran ist, Stromversorgung für deinen Laptop und eben Display-Port. Ich frage mich, ob die Kamera und das Mikrofon sich als USB-Devices anmelden oder ob die nicht tatsächlich über diesen Display-Port reinkommen.
Ich auch.
Ich habe so eine Vermutung. Ich glaube, dass das USB billiger für die Haptom-Mission ist.
Was heißt billiger? Ich meine, so eine Kamera, ich weiß nicht, welche Auflösung die hat, die hat auch schon irgendwie signifikanten Datenstrom. Und das Mikrofon kommt noch mal dazu. Außerdem hast du bei USB immer die bekloppte Latenz. Und so könnten sie halt ein latenzfreies Mikrofon, eine latenzfreie Kamera in ihren Rechner reinkriegen über das Display-Port.
Ich will nur, um billig die Kamera und Mikro da rein zu machen. 95% nutzen das eh nicht. Und...
Latenz interessiert dich immer, wenn du irgendwie eine Applikation herstellst, die iChat heißt. Wir werden es rauskriegen, ich wäre nicht überrascht, wenn Kamera und Mikrofon tatsächlich auch über den Display-Port mit reinkommen. Dann wäre das auf jeden Fall schon mal eine nennenswerte Innovation und wäre auch eine gute Erklärung dafür, warum es jetzt überhaupt so lange gedauert hat mit diesen neuen Displays. Weil die Displays standen schon seit mehreren Jahren, so oft dem müsste mal wieder neu gemacht werden. Alle wollten Kamera und Mikrofon da drin haben. Jetzt haben sie das. Die Frage war halt auch immer, wie schließt du die an? Jetzt gehen sie auf Display-Port und sagen, wenn du Display-Port hast, dann kannst du erstmal große Auflösungen machen. Du hast ein dünnes Kabel, was ja auch noch dazu kommt, weil das ja irgendwie so eine serielle Transmission ist. Du hast ein sehr dünnes Kabel und kannst trotzdem einen 30-Zoll-Bildschirm anschließen und du kannst eben auch im Rückkanal Kamera und Mikrofon darüber fahren. Also ich glaube, dass sie das tun werden. Nicht, dass es von dem Blöden von den Porten eigentlich ist.
Ob du eine Kamera in deinem MacBook hast? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob die Kameras da sind, oder? Und das ist auch über USB angeschlossen.
Die haben alle Kameras.
Das stimmt.
Weißt du, was ich ein hübsches kleines Detail finde an dem neuen MacBook und MacBook Pro? Man kann iPhone-Kopfhörer anschließen und kann die als Headset benutzen.
Das ist wirklich interessant. Ich schätze mal, das geht dann in denselben Eingang wie den Mikro-Eingang. Ich frage mich, was das bedeutet, wenn du sowohl Audio-Inn eingesteckt hast als auch dieses Headset. Achso, meinst du, dass man da noch eine zusätzliche Audioquelle hat? Ich denke, du kannst dann umschalten. Das ist ja derzeit auch schon so. Du hast ja auch den Audio-Eingang und das interne Mikro laufen auch letzten Endes auf demselben Port. Das ist sozusagen nochmal eine unterschiedliche Port-Selektion innerhalb des Build-in-Audio.
Und dass man dann einfach noch eine Auswahl hat mit Zusätzlichen.
Genau, wenn du in dieses Audio-Media-Setup reingehst, dann hast du ja Build-in-Audio und Build-in-Audio unterscheidet dann nochmal in Build-in-Mikrofon und Audio-Eingang. Und da ist wahrscheinlich dann dieser dritte Eingang dann sozusagen nochmal als Alternative. Das wird man abwarten müssen. Ich hab das übrigens mal mit deinem Port nachgeschlagen, was du vorhin behauptet hast. Du hast Recht, bei dem Powermax 6100. Ich kannte diesen Stecker gar nicht, weil ich hatte diesen Computer auch nie. Das ist ein HDMI-45-Port. Und da ist tatsächlich UDB mit drauf gewesen.
A sagt, muss doch USB sagen, so war's.
Hab ich eigentlich schon erzählt, dass ich hier so... Ich hab damals hier meinen iPod irgendwie, also schon so einen älteren iPod, so ein Remote-Dings geholt, also was man unten an diesen Connector ransteckt und nicht in den Kopfhörerbuchse. Und wo man dann am anderen Ende halt auch so ein Plus, Minus, Vorwärts, Rückwärts, Play-Button hat und so einen Clip zum ranstecken, wo man dann auch wieder seinen Kopfhörer reinstecken kann, einen Kürzeren, der auch dabei ist. Und wenn ich das Ding in mein iPhone reinstecke, dann sagt das iPhone ist nicht supported. Früher gab es für ein iPod...
Was war das?
Ich hab's auch nicht verstanden.
Remote heißt es. Genau, da wo auch noch das Radio mit drin ist.
Das Ding.
Ach so. Naja, das ist, was bei den meisten auch mein Universal Doc meldet sich mit, ist nicht supported. Das liegt wahrscheinlich... Das ist großer Scheiß und da haben sie halt was geändert. Wir wollen ja jetzt nicht wirklich über iPhone-Docs reden, oder? Ich wollte mal ein bisschen beim Thema bleiben, weil wir sind gerade beim Display-Port. Können ja gerne noch iPhone noch mit auf die Liste nehmen. Es gab da noch so eine Merkwürdigkeit. Und zwar ist mir aufgefallen, bei MacBook. Bei MacBook steht als Fähigkeit Extended Desktop and Video Mirroring. Bei MacBook Pro steht Dual Display and Video Mirroring. Ist das jetzt nur ein Verschreiber? Meinen Sie in beiden Fällen das gleiche? Oder was? Ich hab keine Ahnung. Ein Extended Desktop ist für mich ein zweiter Bildschirm, wo ich meinen Desktop drauf extende. Aber Dual Display ist für mich auch nichts anderes. Also ich hab den Eindruck, dass sie hier auf diesen beiden Tech-Spec Seiten dasselbe beschreiben mit unterschiedlichen Worten. Oder keine Ahnung, vielleicht bin ich ja irgendeinem Geheimnis aufgesessen. Aber wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, kann auch das neue MacBook ein 30 Zoll Bildschirm treiben.
Also das steht auf jeden Fall da. Simultaneously supports full native resolution on the built-in display and up to pixels on an external display, both at million of colors.
Genau, und die resolution ist 2560 x 1600.
Genau.
Also die Auflösung vom 30 Zoll.
Und das ist exakt die gleiche Beschreibung bei beiden, bloß dass halt dieses, beim einen heißt es extended desktop und beim anderen heißt es dual display.
Vielleicht ist das so wie mit expanded memory und extended memory.
Nee, PC-Shit, oder?
Könnte nicht drüber lachen, ne?
Die hab ich nie gehabt.
Nee, ja. Ja, da gab's extended und expanded memory. Das war sehr lustig. Extended memory war eigentlich das normale, also das waren auch die guten alten Zeiten, als 640 Kilo Bytes so eine magische Grenze waren. Theoretisch konnte der Rechner aber einen Megabyte adressieren. Bloß das war halt irgendwie reservierter Speicherbereich und deswegen gab es halt bei DOS diese Beschränkung auf 640 Kilo Byte nutzbaren Speicher für die Applikation. Irgendwann haben sie dann doch eingesehen, dass vielleicht ein bisschen mehr RAM ganz gut wäre und dann gab es halt zwei Möglichkeiten. Mit dem 286er konnte man es dann halt auch über 1 Megabyte ansprechen und das war dann halt das extended memory. Aber da sie halt irgendwie auch noch so die Backward-Kompatibilität mit 8086 Maschinen irgendwie haben wollten, haben sie sich dann expanded memory ausgedacht. Das hieß vorher LIM-Memory. LIM stand für Lotus, Intel, Microsoft und ihr könnt euch schon etwa vorstellen, was dabei rausgekommen ist. Das war dann sozusagen 64 Kilobyte Bank-Switching. Und du musstest dann sozusagen als Applikation über so ein Control-Port dir dann immer so den Speicher, den du zusetzt, nicht in so 64K-Chunks einblenden, dass du ihn benutzen konntest.
5 oder A20?
A20 geht, das hat damit zu tun. Aber das Grund ist, dass halt nur 1 MB RAM adressierbar war. Aber diese Techniken waren, also beim 80286 konntest du ja mehr RAM adressieren. Aber du hattest halt diese bekloppte Beschränkung. Wie auch immer. Extended, Expanded, Memory, Dual Display, Extended Desktop. Was auch immer sie damit meinen.
Man kann Extended Displays anschließen.
Meine Vermutung ist, es gibt keinen Unterschied, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen beschreiben sie das mit unterschiedlichen Worten. Ist mir nur so aufgefallen, hat ein kleines Fragezeichen hier auf meiner Notizliste bekommen. Dieser Displayport an sich gefällt mir ganz gut und die Kompatibilität zur DVI, HDMI und VGA scheint ja auch sichergestellt zu sein über Adaptern. Also man kann diese Backward-Kompatibility herstellen über diesen Stecker und das haben sie offensichtlich auch getan, sonst hätten sie ja sicherlich ein Problem. Aber es sieht halt ganz so aus, als ob S-Video und Video-Ausgang gestorben sind.
Wir werden sie nicht vermissen, jedenfalls ich nicht.
Was wirst du nicht vermissen? S-Video? S-Video. Na, ich vermisse das auf jeden Fall. Also finde ich als einer der besten Features von meinem MacBook, dass ich das noch habe, weil ich benutze das eigentlich häufig. Na, wenn du an so einen Projektor rangehst, der nur Videoeingang hat, wie willst du das denn sonst machen?
Habe ich nicht das Problem. Also es ist schade für dich, aber für mich ist es kein Problem.
Alte Fernseher und so. Also das ist schon doof, dass das weg ist.
Ich freue mich ja persönlich sehr stark auf dieses neue Touchpad. Buttonlose. Endlich.
Ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig hier mit dem Display-Port. Also, nee, es gibt ja noch ein paar andere schöne Sachen. Also was ich ganz interessant finde, ist die Kabellänge, die dort angegeben werden. Du kannst mit Display-Port einen 30 Zoll Bildschirm mit einem 3 Meter Abstand anhängen. Und du kriegst noch volle HDTV, 1080p Auflösung, also 1920 x 1080, kriegst du auf 15 Meter, genau, mit 60 Hertz. Das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Also so, mein Fernseher, der natürlich wieder keinen Display-Port-Eingang hat, aber hätte er einen, ja, in 15 Metern Entfernung anschließen zu können, das würde einige Probleme lösen. Also man braucht hier nicht mehr solche Repeater, für viele Fälle, offensichtlich. Und Display-Port sieht auch optische Kabel vor. Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt mit den Laptops wahrscheinlich nicht zu machen und damit gibt es dann eben noch sehr viel mehr. Außerdem kann Display-Port auch andere Farbmodelle, außer RGB, die unterstützen halt auch diesen Y, C, B, C, R Farbmodus. Ob sie das nun benutzen, wage ich stark zu bezweifeln, aber in dieser Technologie scheint doch so einiges drin zu sein.
Also das ist dieses Y, M, C, R, das ist Helligkeit und was ist das für? Luminanz und also nicht RGB, sondern dieses... Gott, was war das für Werte? Hilf mir mal raus, Koss. Egal, ist jetzt auch nicht so wichtig.
Ja, also anstatt dass du drei Farben hast, unterscheidest du halt Farbe, Helligkeit und Farbigkeit. Also hast du sozusagen ein Graustufenbild und dann hast du irgendwie eine Sättigung, genau, und die Brightness. Ja, das ist halt ein anderes Farbmodell, was eben so bei digitales Fernsehen benutzt wird. Kameras haben sowas teilweise auch, wie auch immer. Fällt mir noch was ein zum Display-Port? Nö, ich glaube nicht. Fällt euch noch was ein zum Display-Port?
Mir fällt noch was ein und es war immer noch keine zweite Sprache an seinem Laptop anschließen. Dadurch auch nicht, oder?
Doch, also das Display-Port kann beheblich viele Screens. Genau, das ist auch ein Feature von Display-Port.
Wie kann man dann seriell aneinander hängen?
Also der Port selber, das Interface unterstützt, dass du mehrere Screens über einen Kabel schickst. Das heißt, wenn du auf der anderen Seite ein Gerät hast, was auch mehrere Screens hat, dann kann wohl dieses Gerät dem Computer sagen, hallo, ich bin zwei Screens. Was jetzt ein MacBook davon hält und ob es solche Geräte überhaupt schon gibt, das kann ich nicht beantworten.
Das ist eine ganz andere Frage, klar, das ist prinzipiell möglich.
Durch dieses Packet-System ist das alles schön entkoppelt. Du schickst da einfach nur noch Datenströme hin und sagst, was die bedeuten und das kann auch bedeuten, mit hier ist die Bildschirmzeile für den linken Bildschirm und hier ist die für den rechten Bildschirm, sodass man theoretisch mit einem Kabel tatsächlich mehrere ansprechen könnte. Ob du dann noch mal so eine Splitterbox brauchst oder ob es solche Produkte überhaupt geben wird, denke ich, steht derzeit noch in den Sternen. Aber technisch möglich ist es auf jeden Fall.
Das klingt ja mal ganz interessant auf jeden Fall.
Also ich finde, das ist durchaus promising technology. Jetzt muss man nur gucken, wie der Markt da mitzieht. Das wird Apple sicherlich noch einiges zu leisten haben. War auf jeden Fall die mutigste Entscheidung.
Ich habe gerade gesehen, dass die Displayport-Seite bei Wikipedia gerade als... Ja, da gab es so eine Auflösung, was die top aktuellen Seiten sind und da ist Displayport gerade ganz vorne. Alle klicken so Displayport bei der Wikipedia. Seit heute.
Ich habe sie mir gestern.
Okay, kommen wir jetzt zum Trackpad. Ich denke, das ist die andere wichtige Änderung, oder?
Also ich bin ja ein bisschen skeptisch.
Glass Trackpad.
Aber was ich gesehen habe ist, dass es nicht ein Softkey ist, das Touchen. Also genau, man muss erst mal sagen, es gibt keinen Button mehr. Apple hat es geschafft. Keine Buttons mehr. Aber es ist kein Softkey, sondern tatsächlich drückt man dieses Glasteil runter. Hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Das ist ein Button. Also sie sind nach wie vor bei einem Button, nur dass der ganze Trackpad jetzt ein Button ist. Und dass sie im Touch auch noch unterscheiden können, wo du diesen Button drückst, und dadurch können sie im Prinzip beliebig viele Buttons machen und haben halt jetzt serienmäßig auch den Second-Button-Support.
Wobei sie nach wie vor diese Optionen haben. Also man kann glaube ich nach wie vor einstellen, nachdem was ich gehört habe, dass man quasi mit dem Touch klickt, also dass man nicht den Button runterklickt.
Ja, das ist trotzdem immer noch dabei. Und, echt nicht, ich benutze das immer mit Full-Feature-On. Ich benutze irgendwie alle dreizeitverfugstehenden Optionen.
Das finde ich großartig. Ja, weil ich hab mit meinem Finger halt so eine Warteschleife, der kreist immer so wie ein Adler. Und dann entstehen halt Fehlklicks. Deswegen hab ich das mal aus.
Ich stelle fest, dass ich es anhabe als Option, aber nie nutze. Also ich benutze immer die Taste schön tapfer.
Echt? Ich benutze meine Taste nur, wenn ich wütend bin.
Klick, klick, klick. Dann bist du sehr oft wütend.
Oh, ich sehe gerade, ich hab ja auch noch die Möglichkeit mit zwei Finger einen Secondary-Click zu machen.
Das erfährst du jetzt erst? Das ist das Großartigste überhaupt.
Ich erfahre jetzt erst, dass ich das nie eingeschaltet habe, das Feature. Ich benutze ja auch Secondary-Clicks nie.
Also das finde ich noch ganz, also ein Rechtsklick.
Du hast Rechtsklick gesagt, das heißt Sekundärklick. Rechtsklick. Das klingt wie Rechtsruck. Das ist ja furchtbar. Das ist aber Nazi-Taste. Das ist kein Rechtsklick. Das ist Secondary. Und das haben sie übrigens schön gemacht. Also wenn du das Feature bei dem MacBook und MacBook Pro mit dem neuen Button einschaltest, dann ist der normale Klick in der Mitte und die Sekundärklicks sind in der Ecke. Und zwar sowohl in der linken als auch der rechten.
Aber auch in der rechten.
Ja, aber nur weil es auch in der rechten ist, kann man es ja wohl nicht Rechtsklick nennen.
Aber guck mal, bei einer Maus ist das doch immer rechts. Das ist doch mit dem...
Bei einer Microsoft-Maus ist das rechts.
Auch bei einer Apple-Maus.
Bei einer Apple-Maus kannst du das konfigurieren, wie du willst, weil Apple weiß, dass 10% der Bevölkerung Linkshänder sind und dass die mit der anderen Hand...
Ja, ja, ich bin ja selber Linkshänder.
Du bist selber Linkshänder. Und bist du dann ein Unterstützer des Naziklicks?
Bei mir wird es auch bis in aller Ewigkeit nicht abzuhalten.
Das fällt mir übrigens noch was ein, wo wir bei den Linkshändlern sind.
Obwohl mittlerweile kein Abzug.
Ich hoffe...
Es gibt keine Anschlüsse mehr auf der rechten Seite. Es ist jetzt endlich Platz. Ich kann jetzt mein Mousepad direkt neben... Also wenn ich jetzt so ein Gerät hätte, so ein MacBook Pro oder MacBook, kann ich mein Mousepad direkt an den Rand vor den Rechner legen und hab da keine Kabel mehr, die wieder stören, weil bisher ist irgendwie das Ethernet-Kabel geht immer so irgendwie quer über mein Mousepad, weil es halt direkt daneben liegt. Da liegt es ja nicht einen Meter weg von meinem Laptop, sondern es liegt ja direkt daneben. Und jetzt ist da endlich Ruhe. Ja sag ich ja, deswegen ist ja...
Das ist aber nur gut für Rechtshänder. Nee wieso, der muss ja nur den Bildschirm umdrehen. Nee, ich bin von hinten arbeiten. Durch den Apple-Krumm.
Ich benutze sowieso meine Maus... Also wenn ich meine Maus benutze, dann sowieso immer mit rechts. Ich kann die Kabel links halten, vernünftig. Das hab ich... Weil der erste Computer, den ich hatte, den konnte ich nicht alleine nutzen. Darum musste ich jedes Mal die Maus immer umstöpseln, wenn ich dann mal ran wollte. Und darum hab ich mir irgendwann angewöhnt, einfach die Maus mit rechts zu bedienen. Da ist man ja flexibel als Linkshänder.
Du bist aber auch nicht so gnadenlos linkshänderisch, dass du jetzt nicht auch Dinge mit rechts machen könntest?
also ich bin schon ein richtiger... Also es gibt ja so verschiedene Abstufungen, so was man alles mit links macht. Und ich mach eigentlich schon alles, schon sehr viel mit links. Also so schreiben und Tischtennis und so. Diese ganzen Sachen, Tennis spielen. Aber bei der Maus hab ich mich einfach irgendwann ungewönt. Wobei ich früher als Kind auch mal als Hobby dann irgendwann mal gelernt hab, mit rechts zu schreiben. Also, das geht schon alles.
Und im Auto schaltest du da auch mit links?
Jaja, ich hab extra ein englisches Auto gekauft.
Das mach ich doch mit links. Aber vielleicht noch mal zurück zu diesem Trackpad. Genau. Er hat natürlich keinen Bildschirm. Ich freu mich, warum sie Glas genommen haben. Ich vermute, dass es sich hier einfach um dieselbe Technologie handelt wie im iPhone.
Diese Vermutung hab ich auch.
Dass es einfach so ein kapazitiver Bildschirm ist, ohne Bildschirm.
Was ich noch vermute, das Glas ist ja relativ robust, was so Abnutzung angeht. Und ich hab neulich, war mein MacBook Pro in Reparatur und hab dann ne neue Handauflage bekommen und damit ein neues Trackpad. Und da kriegt man ja schon mit, dass ein Trackpad, wenn es neu ist, sich doch komplett anders anfasst, als wenn man es erst mal ein halbes Jahr bedient hat. Und ich hoffe mal, dass die Abnutzungserscheinungen einfach nicht so stark sind bei diesem Glas Trackpad, sondern dass es von der ersten bis zur letzten Sekunde genauso schön anfasst.
Stimmt, in der Mitte ist es auch schön glatt gerubbelt. Außen mal fühlen. Ja, stimmt, in der Mitte ist es glatt und außen ist es rau.
Wozu wurde denn die Space-Taste benutzt? Das ist ja glatt. Bei mir kann man zum Beispiel sehen, dass ich meine Space-Taste mit dem linken Daumen mache.
Stimmt, das kann sein.
Weil da ist es am meisten glatt.
Und ein anderer Grund natürlich für Glas ist, dass sie überhaupt diese Tastenfähigkeit über so eine große Fläche haben. Es muss ja ein extrem unbiegsames, nicht flexendes Material sein. Das Glas bietet sich natürlich auch an.
Na und, wenn man schon so komplett auf Plastik verzichtet und alles nur noch aus Aluminium macht, dann wäre es ja auch doof, genau am Trackpad doch wieder Plastik zu haben.
Aber ich bin ja gespannt, wie sie es drücken lassen.
Ich bin aber...
Sie sind skeptisch eigentlich.
Ich bin vor allem begeistert, dass sie das überhaupt hinbekommen haben. Weil ich meine, wenn man es genau betrachtet, die ganze Fläche ist ein Trackpad. Trotzdem klicke ich auf dem Trackpad. Dann müssen sie ja in der Software zuverlässig und ohne irgendeine nennenswerte Verzögerung unterscheiden können zwischen einer Two-Finger-Gesture und einem One-Finger-Operation mit Ich klicke.
Klikken ist ja ganz einfach, sobald der Kontakt hergestellt ist, oder?
Ja, aber du berührst es ja, bevor du das Ding wirklich drückst.
Aber in der Beziehung, wenn wir dabei schon sind, da wäre ich jetzt mal ein bisschen spekulativ einfach. Ich weiß nicht, habt ihr dieses neue Blackberry-Gerät gesehen?
Du willst schon wieder das Thema wechseln? Ich rede jetzt gerade über diese Problematik mit dem Erkennen des Touches, bevor eigentlich gedrückt wird. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Software-Herausforderung, weil zunächst einmal berührt da zweimal. Und warum wird da nicht gleich ein Sekundärklick, Nazi-Klick, rausgelöst?
Die können ja auch jetzt vier Finger unterscheiden.
Weil es den Zwei-Finger-Klick ja gar nicht mehr gibt.
Ja, aber sie müssen unterscheiden zwischen zwei Fingern, die gemeint sind als zwei Finger, und zwei Finger, die gemeint sind, als gleich Klick der eine. Das ist schon doch ein deutlicher Unterschied. Das ist nicht ohne. Da muss so offen... Mal sehen, also die ersten Berichte sagen, das funktioniert. Und ich frage mich auch, kippelt das Ding eigentlich? Also geht das wirklich gleichmäßig an allen vier Ecken? Oder ist es dafür optimiert, dass man unten klickt? Und hängt das sozusagen oben fest und wird nur an der Unterseite runtergeklickt?
Jede Wette, das geht an allen Punkten genauso runter. Und das ist so eine Wundertechnologie, ist es jetzt auch gar nicht. Jetzt sage ich es doch einfach nochmal. Und zwar dieses neue Blackberry. Wie heißt der? Dieses Touchpad Blackberry.
Old Storm oder was?
Ja, genau. Der hat ja, ne Storm ist der neue. Der hat ja genau diese gleiche, glaube ich, hoffe ich, der hat ja genau dieses gleiche Featurens, nämlich, dass man, die haben ja jetzt auch ein Touchscreen eben, und auch da muss man das Display etwas runterdrücken, wenn man einen Klick auslösen will.
Ja, das ist der ganz normale, drucksensitive Bildschirm, wie er schon seit Ewigkeiten verbaut wird. Das ist alte Technologie.
Nee, nee, das Display gibt nach. Die haben auch so ein Touchdisplay, und das gibt ein bisschen nach. Du klickst, du musst drücken sozusagen, damit das haptische dann...
Ja, das ist ein sogenanntes druckempfindliches Display. Sowas gibt es schon seit 20 Jahren.
Ja, dass die Fläche nachgibt, die gesamte Glasfläche.
Die ganze Glasfläche, bist du sicher, dass das noch funktioniert?
Das bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, dass es genauso funktioniert wie bei dem neuen Apple Trackpad. Und da es aus Glas ist und da es die gleiche Technologie ist wie beim iPhone, wage ich mal einen Vorausblick in die Zukunft, bei welchem Gerät wir das als nächstes sehen werden. Nämlich beim iPhone und beim iPod Touch, glaube ich. Dass es nämlich da auch so einen haptischen Clip-Click geben wird in Zukunft.
Touchscreen with click-through.
Ist ja ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Das soll nur ganz schick sein, wenn man es erstmal rausbekommen hat. Also am Anfang soll es ein bisschen gewöhnungsbedürftig sein, aber nach wenigen Minuten soll es sehr sehr angenehm sein. So ein leichtes Feedback zu haben im Finger, das ist ja... Ich glaube, da könnte ich mich auch beim iPhone ganz gut dran gewöhnen. Das möchte ich bloß nicht immer haben.
Gut, das ist tatsächlich was, das wusste ich noch nicht. Also es ist trotzdem ein kapazitiver Bildschirm. Und irgendwie sits on a springy clickable surface. Ah ja, interessant. Okay, interessant. Das heißt, im Prinzip verwendet der Blackberry Storm dieselbe Technik wie hier mit dem Trackpad.
Das ist meine Vermutung.
Aber warum? Aber ich meine, wozu braucht man denn das da an der Stelle, wo niemand das gewohnt ist?
Na, ich nehme mal an für die Blackberry-User, die es gewöhnt sind, dass sie kleine Tasten drücken, physische, dass sie noch ein bisschen dieses Sensation haben. Und wie gesagt, es gibt auch beim, da hat Nokia mal mit rum experimentiert, mit diesem Nokia 770, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt. Das waren diese kleinen Linux-Dinger, die die hatten. Und die haben auch hinter dem Display eingebaut gehabt, mal so einen kleinen Piezo-Kristall, den sie auch explizit steuern konnten darüber, wo sie dann auch wirklich ein Feedback geben konnten. Und haben damit mal ein bisschen rum experimentiert und haben festgestellt, dass die Leute, wenn sie auf sowas mit dem Finger tippen, das Gefühl haben, schneller zu tippen. Sie tippen zwar nicht wirklich schneller, die Tipprate steigt nicht, aber man hat das Gefühl, schneller zu tippen. Und ich glaube, genau sowas könnte beim Blackberry ganz entscheidend sein und würde für Apple auch nicht ganz gerade schlecht stehen. Und diesen physischen Klick zu haben, ich leg da Wert drauf, was das Trackpad angeht. Und warum beim iPhone kann ich es mir sicherlich genauso gut vorstellen. Und gerade bei Apple vermute ich mal, dass die dann sogar noch mehr Gesten haben. Also dass es dann Safari so was vielleicht wie ein Hover geben wird, aber eben noch mal zusätzlichen Klick oder irgendwie sowas. Aber das wird die Zukunft zeigen.
Vielleicht zurück zu der Notebook-Technologie. Eins gibt es nicht. Zwei Sachen gibt es nicht. Weder GPS noch UMTS sind da. Finde ich persönlich ein bisschen schade. Nicht, dass ich jetzt dringend damit gerechnet hätte. Hat man ja letztes Mal schon durchgekraut, aber toll hätte ich es trotzdem gefunden. Finden sie wohl offensichtlich noch nicht so wichtig.
Ah, also bei GPS wäre ich ja mal sehr gespannt gewesen, was da für ein Aufschrei durch die entsprechenden Medien gegangen wäre. Von wegen Apple ist böse, weil die überwachen uns doch bestimmt alle. Ich meine, das ging ja beim iPhone schon rum.
Bei GPS? Warum sollte man bei einer passiven Technologie, die keinerlei Überwachungsfunktionalität hat, von Überwachung sprechen? Das ist doch blöd.
Weil es geht.
Weil was geht?
Also beim iPhone ist es ja passiert.
Was passiert denn da passiert? Da gab es mal kurz Aufregung darüber. Die Free Software Foundation hat diese sinnlose Liste von...
Stimmt, Free Software Foundation war das.
Ja, das ist... Ich kann da nur schwer atmen, wenn ich das mal so sagen darf. Ich meine, alle Leute freuen sich darüber, dass sie so einen Location-Feature haben und das dann gleichzeitig als böse dahin zu stellen. Das ist dann wirklich Quatsch. Weil die Behauptung war, dass es alles automatisch und ohne dass der Benutzer was davon weiß, übermittelt wird, das ist einfach nicht wahr. Weil die Programme, wie wir ja alle wissen, vorher sozusagen, wenn sie darauf zugreifen, dass das Betriebssystem sicherstellt, dass der User vorher gefragt wird. Und daher ist das wirklich Blödsinn. Also ich finde nach wie vor, GPS wäre es wert, auch in ein Laptop mit reingebracht zu werden. Ich verstehe auch, dass das jetzt nicht eins der Features ist, nach denen die Leute am meisten schreien. Bei UMTS, denke ich, gibt es schon so ein bisschen Schreirei. Das ist aber wahrscheinlich vor allem eine europäische Schreierei, weil das bei uns einfach schon so gut ausgebaut ist. Und wir uns schon an den Gedanken gewöhnt haben, dass man für relativ wenig Geld im Monat brauchbare Datenflatrates bekommt. Davon ist die USA, Nordamerika im Allgemeinen und auch andere Länder wahrscheinlich noch weiter von entfernt. Aber diese Situation kann sich auch schnell ändern.
Und wenn es kommt, dann wird es natürlich, oder gehe ich mal fest von aus, dass es so kommt, dass auch entsprechende Angebote gleich mitgemacht werden mit den entsprechenden Partnerprogrammen bei den Herstellern.
Sicherlich, genau. Aber scheint offensichtlich nicht auf der Agenda zu sein. Was ist noch neu? Ja, das finde ich sehr schön. Ich finde auch das höhere Modell reizvoller. Allein deshalb schon, aber auch von der Performance her. Das ist ja immerhin nochmal 0,4 MHz schneller.
Richtig.
0,4 MHz.
Genau. 400 MHz.
Also schon ein Fünftel mehr Power. Das sollte man merken. Zumal ja auch mehr Cash und solche Sachen mit einherziehen. Und man kriegt mehr Platte serienmäßig und tralala. Ob es einem jetzt den Aufpreis wert ist, weiß ich nicht. Aber das ist das MacBook überhaupt schon mal mit Hintergrundbeleuchtung, finde ich gut.
Aber das ist doch in beiden Versionen mit Hintergrundbeleuchtung, oder?
Hintergrundbeleuchtung?
Keyboardbeleuchtung, meine ich ja.
Die kleine Version von MacBook hat das nicht. Das hast du nur bei der großen. Aber ist es jetzt überhaupt das erste Mal überhaupt in MacBook verfügbar, aber eben nur bei der teureren Version, die du für 1500 Euro kriegst?
Also ich hab mich damals bei meinem MacBook Pro wie bolle drüber gefreut, dass ich jetzt auch endlich Tastatur-Hintergrund-Beleuchtung habe und nutze es exakt nie, um ehrlich zu sein. Also ich tippe dunkeln, einfach dann dunkel weiter und ich komm nicht mal drauf. Wobei, ein bisschen liegt es auch daran, dass es so in Dämmerlicht-Verhältnissen sieht man manchmal mit eingeschalteter Tastatur-Hintergrund-Beleuchtung eher weh.
Die Automatik, die Apple da eingebaut hat, die war nicht... Ist die immer noch scheiße?
Also ich meine, das ist halt F8, F9 und F10. Nur für die Hintergrundbeleuchtung. Was ist das für ein Scheiß? Da gibt es F8 nur zum Ein- oder Ausschalten, und F9 dunkler und F10 heller. Und ich meine, die Displaybeleuchtung, da gibt es ja auch nur zwei Tasten. Da hab ich ja auch nicht eine extra Taste, um sie komplett auszumachen. Also das verschwendet die Taste. Aber ich glaub, bei den neueren Tastaturen, auch bei diesen flachen Alu-Tastaturen, haben sie es wohl komplett neu belegt. Da ist es gar nicht mehr so.
Ja, ich schau gerade mal. Ja, ich guck grad mal hier. Die haben noch schöne hochauflösende Bilder hier irgendwo. Da muss doch auch irgendwo die Tastatur zu sehen sein. Jetzt bin ich gerade auf dem falschen Gerät gelandet. Ich glaub, das ist nicht mehr so. Warte mal.
Auf dem hier hätte man vielleicht eine Scheiße.
Da gab's doch so schöne Features.
Kannste aber schon bei den Alu-Tastaturen sehen. Ich glaub, das ist auch schon nicht mehr so.
Doch, doch, doch.
Aber hatten die schon auf allen drei Tassen?
Es ist F6. F6 zumindest. Ne, nur F6 scheint mir... Also es scheint nur ein An-Aus, kein heller, dunkler Spendier zu haben. Aber F6 ist das Symbol für Hintergrundbeleuchtete Tastatur. Ich schätze mal, das dürfte es dann sein.
Aber, wenn wir dabei sind, die Num-Lock-Taste ist endlich tot. Gott sei Dank. Die war ja schon bei den neueren MacBooks tot, aber jetzt auch beim MacBook Pro.
Es gibt keine mehr.
Ja, das war auch...
Also, der Num-Lock war doch F6, oder?
Den nutzt man eigentlich nie.
Ja, genau.
Das haben sie jetzt sozusagen durch die Num-Lock-Beleuchtung gesetzt.
Da kommt man immer noch drauf und wundert sich, was da für ein Scheiß auf dem Bildschirm erscheint. Und...
Genau.
Das ist als nächstes gleich mal Caps Lock abschalten. Ach nee, haben sie ja schon. Da gibt es ja jetzt diesen Trick, das haben sie da auch mit den Alu-Tastaturen eingeführt.
Caps Lock kann man abschalten. Caps Lock hab ich abgeschalten.
Und wer numerisches Keypad braucht, der kann eine passende Applikation aus dem App Store laden und sein iPhone als Numpad benutzen.
Ah, der hat vielleicht sogar schon Geld ausgegeben. Aber ich sehe gerade hier, es geht nur noch heller und dunkler bei der Tastaturbeleuchtung. Es gibt nicht mehr die Scheiterein-Taste-Ausschalt-Taste. Genau, eine Taste weniger. Eine Reduktion um ein Dürbel.
Hat ja auch Jonathan Ive schon gesagt, wenn man irgendwo noch was... Wie hat das gesagt? Wenn er ein Gerät nennen müsste, wo man nichts mehr wegsparen könnte, dann wär's das neue MacBook Pro. Sie haben halt auch diese Taste eingespart.
Aber die Caps Lock-Taste gibt's noch.
Die hab ich übrigens abgeschaltet. Hab ich schon erwähnt, wie man die Caps Lock-Taste abschaltet im MacBook? Ich glaube, es spielt überhaupt keine Rolle, an welchem Rechner. Und zwar gibt's im Tastatur- und Maus-Kontrollfeld den Punkt Sondertasten, wo man die Taste neu belegen kann. Feststell-Taste, Control-Taste, Alt-Taste und Apfel-Taste. Und da kann man auch sagen, keine Aktion. Und seitdem ist meine...
Warte, warte, das muss ich jetzt live machen.
Meine Caps Lock-Taste, keine Taste mehr. Genau. Und da unten links?
Und links bei Keyboard Shortcuts, oder wo? Da bin ich.
Genau.
Ne, nicht bei Keyboard Shortcuts, sondern bei Keyboard.
Und dann Caps Lock, tatsächlich, no action, yeah.
Ich hätte gerne eine Shift-Taste draus gemacht oder sowas, oder eine Abfüll-Taste. Oh, gerne.
Ich benutze nie Caps Lock.
Sehr schrecklich.
Ich benutze das häufig.
Und was mir gerade auffällt, wenn man da einfach mal eben, guck, da kann man auch noch eine zusätzliche Abfüll-Taste draus machen, dann kann man viel leichter Abfüll tappen. Jetzt hab ich gerade mein Leben gerettet. Zwei Leben an einem Tag.
Das ist doch schön.
Und Tim ist genervt, weil er die Caps Lock-Taste trotzdem noch mag.
Ich mag die Caps Lock-Taste. Ich mag auch die Enter-Taste. Aber ich find's trotzdem okay, dass sie nicht mehr als solche auf dem Keyboard ist, weil man sie immer noch über FN erreichen kann. Das find ich völlig in Ordnung.
Dass sie jetzt eine rechte Alt-Taste geworden ist. Aber das ist auch schon bei den späteren MacBooks so gewesen.
Jaja, das gibt's schon seit einiger Zeit, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, ansonsten finde ich... Also, ich find... Wir haben jetzt noch gar nicht so über das Design allgemein geredet. Oder? Ich find die echt schick geworden. So, zumindest auf den Fotos. Ich mag die richtig, richtig gerne. Endlich mal, seit wann? Seit wann ist jetzt dieses dämliche Alugehäuse beim MacBook Pro und beim Powerbook und weiß ja teufel was? Seit wann gibt's das tolle Titanium nicht mehr? Seit 2002? 2002 oder 2003?
Fandest du das toller als das aktuelle?
Das Titanium? Von der Praktikabilität her nicht. Also ich mein, das war ja furchtbar anfällig und alles. Aber vom Praktikabilität heißt es. Praktikabilität. Von der Praktikabilität her war es ganz furchtbar. Wie vermutlich jeder weiß, der eins hatte jemals.
Ja, es war furchtbar weich und instabil.
Und ich glaube, es bei ungefähr jedem Gerät irgendwann mal hinten dieses blöde Scharnier rausgebrochen.
Aber ich meine, die neuesten Geräte sind natürlich... Also ich finde das jetzt vom ersten Blick......die neue Technik assoziiert und all sowas. Deswegen natürlich sind immer die neuesten Geräte das Coolste. Und dieses Unibody ist schon cool. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wie schön steif das ist.
Ich fand das aktuelle Gehäuse, fand ich immer ein bisschen......joa, ein bisschen sehr auf Business reduziert. Also ein bisschen... da fehlt irgendwie der Kontrast. Und ehrlich gesagt, dieses spiegelnde MacBook Pro Schrift, die fand ich von Anfang an ganz furchtbar.
Spiegelnde MacBook Pro Schrift?
Das steht ja... unterunter steht ja da MacBook, beziehungsweise MacBook Pro, und das ist bei den Geräten in Silber. Also man spiegelt sich theoretisch da drin, das finde ich ganz ganz unerträglich. So aus Design-Perspektive. Ich glaube, da sind die neuen echt ein ganz ganz großer Schritt nach vorne. Aber wisst ihr, was sich bei Apple nicht geändert hat?
Auch bei diesen neuen Laptops wahrscheinlich nicht? Der Einschaltton, der ist doch immer noch so wie vor 45 Jahren, oder?
Na, das hat sich schon häufig verändert. Also unterschiedliche Macs hatten unterschiedliche Einschalttöne, aber in letzter Zeit sind sie bei dem einen geblieben.
Bei der PowerPC-Einführung, ne? Kann das sein?
Ich glaub, das kann sein. Davor haben sie regelmäßig mal geändert.
Weil langsam, ehrlich gesagt, ist es ein bisschen peinlich schon.
Peinlich, man schaltet ja immer...
Okay, Gott sei Dank, aber alle gucken dann immer gleich.
Na, die würden auch beim anderen tun.
Weil es so uncool ist. Oh Gott, hat schon wieder einer gebootet. Das ist der Lame.
Ich hab hier gerade mal so einen Artikel rausgesucht, wo die Geschichte dieses Einschalt-Tons drinne steht.
Haben sie ja von irgendeinem Musiker so teuer machen lassen, ne?
Genau, das muss ich irgendwann mal rentieren. Aber das ist vielleicht des Steve Jobs ja in Wirklichkeit taub, weil ich meine, so wie er sonst auf alle Details achtet und wie oft ist der Apple seitdem umdesignt worden, seitdem der wieder da ist. Aber der Sound ist immer noch derselbe, das natürlich...
Na, die finden den wohl noch okay. Ich kann dem jetzt auch nicht so widersprechen. Das ist halt einfach der Einschalt-Sound. Ich meine, ursprünglich war es mal der Einschalt-Sound, weil da hat sich das schon ein bisschen gebessert.
Dieser ganz einfache.
Naja, klar.
Aber es gab zwischendurch auch mal so richtig... Schicke, die noch ein bisschen satter waren als der aktuelle.
Was hättest du denn gern?
Also ich weiß nicht. Ich finde den auch nach wie vor relativ hübsch. Ich meine, in Volley gerade, falls irgendjemand den Film gesehen hat, da taucht der ja auch auf. Aber ich mag den schon gerne. Aber so viel, wie sich bisher geändert hat, warum nicht auch irgendwann mal der Einschalt-Sound? Und das ist ja doch die allererste Erfahrung, die so ein frischer Mac-User mit seinem Mac hat. Ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass gerade Steve Jobs da wahrscheinlich sitzen irgendwo in Copatino 48 Musiker eingesperrt, die die ganze Zeit nichts anderes machen, als neue Einschalt-Sounds zu produzieren.
Ich glaube, die booten alle so selten. Die hören sich jetzt unsere Sendung an und merken erstmal, dass da Bedarf besteht.
Wegen Mobile Macs wird das jetzt auf den Wall-E-Sound umgeändert. Dann bootet das Ding mit Wall-E.
Ich glaube, dann würde ich meinen Rechen aus dem Fenster schmeißen.
Kommen wir dann nochmal zu den Änderungen und Neuigkeiten. Eine Änderung ist der Bildschirm. Alle sind jetzt glossy. Es gibt die matte Option nicht mehr. Auch da wird es wieder bei bestimmten Klientels zu Schreiereien führen. Wobei ich ja sagen muss, ich lebe jetzt schon eine Weile mit diesem glossy Display. Ich hatte da auch vorher so meine Bedenken, aber ich kann diese Bedenken überhaupt nicht füttern mit irgendeiner Erfahrung. Also das sieht einfach schick aus.
Es ist viel glasklarer, wieder so wie früher. Wenn ihr euch noch an die Zeit erinnern könnt, wo Monitore nicht entspiegelt waren. Das war doch einfach viel schickere aus. Und dann kam diese entspiegelten Monitore. Ich dachte mir, was ist denn das für eine graue Scheiße da vorne? Das ging überhaupt gar nicht. Und jetzt ist es wieder so, wie es früher war.
Endlich.
Ernsthaft? Du freust dich auf... Also ich bin nach wie vor relativ skeptisch. Und ich hab... also das einzige Mal, als ich ein bisschen Erfahrung mit so einem spiegelnden Display gemacht habe, das war vielleicht auch ein extrem spiegelndes Gerät. Das war dieses HP Mini Note, was die mir irgendwann mal zugeschickt hatten. Und das fand ich schon nervig spiegelig. Also das war so, sobald es draußen hell war, hat es mich wirklich doch mehrfach gestört. Ich fahre den ganzen Sommer über draußen, wenn es hell war.
Aber selbst wenn es draußen hell ist, siehst du halt auf diesen neuen Displays was. Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit dieser Glossy-Screen dazu beiträgt oder ob das nur daran liegt, dass die leuchtkräftiger geworden sind.
Ja auch.
Aber ich kann einfach an diesen Dinger nichts aussetzen. Ich finde die einfach okay.
Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt, weil es ja jetzt auch eine Glas-Oberfläche ist, ja doch noch mal ein bisschen was anderes als diese Kunststoff-Oberfläche, die da bisher drin war, auch bei den Glossys. Das war doch kein Glas. Und, na, werden wir mal sehen, was dabei rumkommt. Aber auf jeden Fall schick ist es natürlich auf jeden Fall, diese komplette Glasfront da vorne zu haben.
Was ich noch ein bisschen schade finde, wenn wir beim Display sind, ist, dass beim 17 Zoll wird ja als Option angeboten, dass man anstelle von 1680 auf 1920 gehen kann. Kostet glaube ich 100 Euro, ne? Dann hat man eine Höhe auflösendes Display. Das gibt es das 15 Zoll leider nicht.
Ja, das wäre schick gewesen. Das hatten wir letzte Woche schon. Das hattest du gehofft, dass das bekommen wird?
Ja, das ist jetzt nicht gekommen.
Am Sonnabend? Und ist nicht gekommen, leider. Ich würde ja durchaus mit dem kleinen MacBook liebäugeln, wenn es eine höhere Auflösung hätte als die 1280. Also das wäre ja... Ich mag die kleinen MacBooks sehr, sehr gerne, außer das Display. Das ist mir zu klein. Also hat mir eine zu geringe Auflösung.
Dafür gibt es halt jetzt den externen Bildschirm.
Der passt nicht in die U-Bahn.
Ja, aber ich will keinen externen Bildschirm. Genau, der passt nicht in meine Scrum-Platform.
Der Bildschirm übrigens hat auch nur 1920. Das heißt, er hat 24 Zoll, also einen Zoll größer als das, was ich jetzt habe, hat aber die gleiche Auflösung. Das ist auch ein bisschen schade, hätten auch ein bisschen hochdrehen können.
Die gleiche Auflösung.
Ich hab hier 23 Zoll. Das neue LED-Display hat 24 Zoll, aber immer noch 1.920.
Kann das sein, dass die einfach anders messen? Dass die so, hä, hä, jetzt kriegt ja keiner mehr mit, wo das Display zu Ende ist, weil wir haben eine komplette Glasfront drüber und messen einfach das eine Zoll.
Nein, sondern die bewerben halt mit 24 Zoll. Mehr wissen die Leute doch eh nicht. Die wissen ja gar nicht, was Pixel sind. Habe ich manchmal das Gefühl.
Pixel sind auch nicht das Einzige, was wichtig ist. Auch die Größe spielt eine Rolle. Da kommt es nicht unbedingt immer auf die Pixel an, sondern auch darüber, wie weit sich das erstreckt. Wir haben jetzt hier zum Beispiel bei Blinkenlites mit HDTV-Monitoren gearbeitet. Die haben nur diese 1366 x 768 Auflösung gehabt, waren aber 40 Zoll. Da wurde dann hier kräftig im Peer-Modus programmiert. Das war eigentlich super geil. Da passt dir jetzt auch nicht so extrem viel mehr drauf, als auf den Screen. Aber die Tatsache, dass der Bildschirm einfach groß war, machte einen riesen Unterschied, weil du einfach auch von sehr weit weg, du kannst so 2-3 Meter vor diesem Bildschirm sitzen und du saßt halt immer noch alles. Wenn du jetzt eine höhere Auflösung hast, dann musst du dann doch wieder näher ran. Da passt dann zwar mehr drauf, aber das ist nur das eine Argument. Das andere Argument ist, Leute wollen es auch größer, damit sie es aus einer größeren Betrachtungsperspektive, also aus einem größeren Abstand her, auch noch sehen können. Also das ist nicht immer alles nur diese eine Sache mit mehr Pixel, auch wenn ich das verstehen kann, sondern größer ist manchmal auch größer.
Aber wenn ich größer haben will, stelle ich mir die kleinere Auflösung einfach ein und dann habe ich es in größer.
Klar, aber kostet auch Geld und lalala. Und dieses neue Teil finde ich es echt günstig. Also für 900 Euro mit Lautsprecher. Achso, ich habe noch gar nicht gekostet, was in Deutschland kostet.
Na ja, aber ist das günstig? Ich habe heute bei, als ich auf der Suche nach den MacBooks war, nach den neuen habe ich gesehen, also es waren kleinere, das waren so im 20 Zoll Bereich, aber die gingen da so für 180 Euro über den Tisch. Das ist klar, das ist bestimmt eine andere Qualität und sowas.
Ja, da hast du ganz andere Einblickwinkel. Ich meine, da guckst du ein bisschen von rechts, dann siehst du halt nichts mehr.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass man für 500, 600 Euro schon sehr, sehr gute Displays bekommt in der Größenordnung, oder?
Ja, aber keine, die ordentlich verarbeitet schick aussehen, irgendwie einen aktuellen Bildschirm Displayport haben und Lautsprecher und Kamera.
Ja, ich sag ja gar nichts gegen das Gerät, aber super billig ist es jetzt nicht.
Super billig ist gar nichts bei Apple, aber es ist ein korrekter Preis. Also ich würde sofort zuschlagen, wenn ich meinem Mac Mini beibringen könnte, einen Displayportmonitor anzusteuern. Und das kann ich halt nicht. Aber ich hoffe, dass sie sehr bald die Mac Minis aktualisieren werden, weil sie haben ja jetzt angekündigt, dass sie alles auf Displayport umstellen und ich denke, sie werden diese Umstellung eher schneller als langsamer machen.
Na, sie müssen es eher schneller als langsam machen, weil es gibt im Augenblick offensichtlich jetzt von Apple kein Display mehr. Oder gibt es diese 30 Zoll Displays noch mal?
Sie verkaufen die alten noch. Aber sie bewerben sie nicht gerade besonders auffällig. Genauso übrigens wie das 17 Zoll MacBook Pro. Da gibt es zwar ganz versteckt unten auf der Seite einen Link. Aber wenn du so durch die normale Menüstruktur durchmarschierst, dann hast du echte Probleme sowohl das 17 Zoll als auch noch das alte weiße MacBook zu finden. Die sind zwar im Verkauf, aber du musst schon wissen, wonach du suchst. Du wirst als Neukunde nicht drauf geschlossen.
Das weiße MacBook, das findet man noch relativ leicht. Das ist doch direkt mit auf der Seite.
Im Store. Aber nicht auf der eigentlichen und hier ist unsere Produktpalette-Webseite.
Ah, stimmt, das ist auch nicht mehr. Ja, aber das ist sowieso mal komplett Apple-untypisch, oder? Was? So dieses alte Geräte noch weiterverkaufen. So einen Abverkauf quasi zu machen. Also normalerweise kannte man das doch bisher immer so, wenn das neue Gerät kam, dann gab es das, und dann gab es nichts anderes mehr. Und das ist jetzt ja gerade bei MacBook, das sieht ja so aus, als ob sie das noch ein bisschen weiter produzieren wollen, oder?
Nee, das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass sie das machen. Sie haben schon häufiger nochmal die alte Modell-Generation für eine Weile weitergetragen, solange sie dieses Preissegment nicht bedienen können. Weil hätten sie das jetzt nicht noch im Angebot, dann hätten sie als Mindesteinstieg 1300 Euro. Und damit können sie derzeit im Markt nichts holen, aber dafür haben sie jetzt ein Gerät, was sie für, was kostet es? 950 Euro anbieten können. Und das ist natürlich ein ordentlicher... ein ordentlicher Preis, finde ich, für das aktuelle weiße MacBook. Ich finde es nur schade, dass es das nur in weiß gibt. Also in schwarz würde ich es mir ja gleich nochmal kaufen.
Also ich finde... ah, das ist schon sehr schick, das neue MacBook.
Tja, du willst eins haben, du willst eins haben. Und weißt du was das Schlimme ist? Ich will ein MacBook Pro, plus Display natürlich.
ich nehme eins ohne Display. MacBook Pro ohne Display. Gerne die kleine Version.
Ihr wollt das dicke haben. Mir ist das zu schwer. Und es ist ja sogar noch schwerer geworden als es vorher war. Und ich finde das MacBook ist cool. Aber jetzt kommen wir zu dem leidigen Thema. Sie haben Firewire gekillt.
Aber das ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen langsam so wie Kenny töten, oder? Das ist, Firewire stirbt einen langsam tot, aber einen regelmäßigen.
You bastard, sag ich nur. Also ich finde, das war jetzt noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Was ich ja die spannende Frage finde, warum eigentlich? Also es muss doch wirklich daran liegen, dass sie einfach den Port nicht nach draußen weitergeleitet haben.
Weil das Geld kostet.
Die Lizenzgebühren, die sie an sich selber zahlen müssten, meinste?
Die zahlen sie nicht an sich selber, sondern die zahlen sie erstens an die, also sie zahlen die Lizenzgebühr, in dem der Lizenzgebühr zahlt der Chip-Hersteller und den Chip, den sie da verbauen, der kostet Geld. Und so ein Firewire-Stein macht schon so eine normale Festplatte um 30 Euro teurer. Und selbstverständlich macht das auch ein MacBook um 30 Euro teurer.
Ja, das ist aber nur ein Premium-Preis.
Wahrscheinlich ist es im NVIDIA-Chip sogar schon mit drin.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Da fehle ich euch mal den Chaos Radio Express Podcast zum Thema USB. Wo diese Frage auch kurz aufkam. Du zahlst einfach extrem viel Geld für Firewire. Das ist teure Technologie, weil da so viel Lizenzkohle drin ist. Und bei USB fällt das alles weg. Außerdem ist es so, dieser Chipset hat halt kein Firewire eingebaut. Niemand baut Firewire ein in diese ganze Chipsets-Geschichte. Das heißt, um Firewire zu haben, muss Firewire explizit hinzugefügt werden. Und was es auch immer kostet, es kostet. Und auch Apple, die jetzt in Anführungsstrichen Premium-Produkte verkaufen, schaut natürlich auf die Kosten. Und sie schauen sich auch bei jedem Interface an, brauchen wir das noch wirklich oder nicht? Und ich denke, sie sehen es einfach so. Ich werde wieder alles schreien. MacBook ist Consumer. Und Consumer kriegt alles in USB. Ich meine, sie haben es ja vorher noch schön ausgebreitet, dass nach wie vor 50% aller Leute, die in ihre Apple-Stores reindackeln, sind halt Leute, die new to the Mac sind. Sie gewinnen extrem viele, und vor allem mit dem MacBook, extrem viele Neukunden dazu. Und das sind Leute, die haben von Firewire noch nie was gehört.
Aber was ist denn aus den ganzen tollen Videokameras geworden, aus diesem Videoschnitt, den wir alle vor wenigen Jahren noch gemacht haben? Womit machen die Leute heute ihren Videoschnitt? USB.
Die haben jetzt alle USB 2.0 und mounten direkt als Platte. Und diese alte Scheiße mit irgendwie ich schließe meine Firewire-Kamera an und übertrage meine Bilder in 1 zu 1 Geschwindigkeit, das ist jetzt vorbei.
Aber die gibt es doch noch überall. Jedes Geschäft hat doch noch diese Kameras rumliegen. Massenhaft, oder? Was wäre denn die Alternative dazu, wenn ich bewegte Bilder machen will? USB. Aber dann geht ja gar kein Mini-DV.
Nee, Mini-DV ist Firewire. Verstehe ich dich jetzt gerade falsch?
Nee, ich meine das Band, das Mini-DV-Band.
Es will auch keiner mehr Bänder haben. Diese Geräte haben jetzt RAM, also Flash-RAM, oder Festplatten drin.
Ist das nicht noch ziemlicher Premium-Bereich? Also ich hab mich lange nicht mehr damit beschäftigt, aber ich glaube, das ist schon noch eher Premium-Bereich, dass im Consumer-Bereich doch noch relativ viel mit Bändern gemacht wird.
Die Leute wollen jetzt HD haben, die Leute wollen jetzt irgendwie schnell auf ihre Videos zugreifen können, die wollen Random Access haben, aber niemand will sich mehr hinsetzen. Schnell ist Random Access, und du kannst halt so eine Kamera einfach über USB anschließen, wie eine Festplatte, und dann kannst du auf deinen Clip direkt zugreifen und ihn als Datei auf deinen Rechner schieben, versus du startest deine Movie-Software und lädst es eins zu eins in Bandspeed auf deinen Computer. Also wir bewegen uns einfach weg von diesen Devices, und schon die neue Version von iMovie hat ja klar gemacht, wo da die Präferenzen sind, weil sie eben auch nicht mehr alles unterstützen, was das alte iMovie unterstützt hat. Also klar, es gibt jetzt halt noch die Installed Base und die alten Kameras, das ist das eine, die noch Firewire haben. Dann haben wir natürlich die Leute, die noch Festplattensysteme und Rates vor allem benutzen, für Backup und so weiter. Und wo es natürlich jetzt auch ganz wüst zutrifft, zuschlägt, und da muss ich sagen, da haben sie echt Mut, dass sie das jetzt machen, das ist natürlich der Audiobereich. Im Audiobereich, jeder halbwegs seriöser, jedes halbwegs seriöse Audio-Interface wird über Firewire angeschlossen. Und im USB hast du nur 1, 2, 3 Port-Dinger und sehr wenig, was jetzt wirklich so in den Midrange-Bereich reingeht. Aber da werden sie dann halt...
Aber Leute, die halt auf Audio machen mit ihrem Rechner, sind ja schon eigentlich eher Profis und gehören halt ins 15 Zoll-Lager.
Genau, aber auch die Leute hätten sich mal über ein leichteres Gerät gefreut. Also ich meine, ich sehe mich ja selber so ein bisschen in dem Lager. Also ich hätte halt wirklich liebend gern auch noch Firewire noch länger in meinem Gerät gehabt. Muss mich aber jetzt sozusagen entscheiden zwischen teurer Computer oder eben dieses Interface. Und die Entscheidung hätte ich ganz gerne erst in einem oder zwei Jahren gemacht. Und jetzt sehe ich mich eben in der Situation, dass ich sie jetzt machen muss. Und wenn wir sagen, im Zweifelsfall, käle ich eher Firewire, als dass ich mir einen teuren Computer kaufe. Ich bin aber auch kein Musiker. Ich bin zwar Podcaster und habe es mit Firewire-Interfaces probiert, aber die haben Latenzprobleme und sowieso taugt für mich alles herzlich wenig. Von daher habe ich das eh wieder alles abgestoßen. Trotzdem, es fehlt einfach noch was, weil derzeit ist die Qualität der USB 2.0-Interfaces in Bezug auf Latenz und Vielseitigkeit irgendwie noch nicht da. Aber ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass das jetzt schnell aufgeholt wird, weil auch im Audiobereich geht alles auf USB 2.0.
Ja, iPhone ist USB, die iPods sind USB, alles ist USB.
Ich denke, Firewire hat einfach keine nennenswerte Zukunft mehr. Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass Apple da noch lange mit weitermarschiert. Ich denke, dass die Pro-Desktops und die Pro-Laptops das noch für eine ganze Weile lang weiterführen werden. Aber ab dem MacBook nach unten ist jetzt einfach vorbei. Und auch die Displays werden es nicht mehr haben.
Wahrscheinlich das nächste MacBook Pro auch schon nicht mehr. Das nächste Gehäusegeneration wird ein paar Jahre dauern.
Das wissen wir nicht. Ich denke, für die nächsten zwei Jahre wird es auf jeden Fall noch Firewire geben im Pro-Segment. Ganz klar. Sonst würden sie ihren kompletten Audiomarkt verlieren. Sie entwickeln Logic. Die wissen, wie das aussieht. Die Musiker haben ihre Geräte lange. Ich wäre überrascht, wenn sie es in den nächsten fünf Jahren fallen lassen. Ich wäre aber nicht überrascht, wenn wir bei Firewire 800 nicht hinausgehen. Das eher damit zu rechnen ist, dass wir bald ein USB 3.0 kriegen, was sich dann auch in allen Geräten wiederfindet und was dann in Bezug auf Performance und Features auch gleichzieht.
Aber was jetzt natürlich in dem Zusammenhang ganz lustig ist, dass das kleinste MacBook, was 250 Euro günstiger ist als das nächstgrößere, das hat noch Firewire. Und das hat auch zumindest formell etwas schnelleren Prozessor sogar als die nächstgrößere Generation. Weil das kleinste hat 2,1 Gigahertz, das weiße. Und natürlich Firewire. Weil es ist ja noch das alte Gerät und das nächstgrößere hat keinen Firewire mehr und nur zwei Gigahertz Prozessoren.
Aber es ist nicht schneller. Weil du hast einen viel schnelleren Frontside-Bus und die ganze Systemarchitektur. Also der Prozessor wird seine 100 Gigahertz nicht ausspielen können.
Das glaube ich nicht.
Aber rein formell, also von dem, was der Kunde sieht, der Einsteigerkunde, sagt er, da steht 2,1, da steht 2,0.
Wenn der Kunde noch an den Gigahertz-Mythos glaubt, dann ist das natürlich so. Von daher denke ich, werden sie auch noch eine ganze Menge von diesen weißen Dingern loswerden, weil die sind ja durchaus beliebt.
Das ist ja auch gar nicht so schlecht.
Aber einen Transfer-Mode hat man ja nicht mehr, wenn man keinen Firewire mehr hat, ne?
Target Disk Mode meinst du, ne?
Stimmt, wie geht das eigentlich in Zukunft? Wie kriege ich meine Daten? Achso, ne, ich hab ja auch in Zukunft einen MacBook Pro einfach, damit hat sich der Salat, brauch ich bloß 400, 800 Kabel.
Du kriegst deine Daten über Gigabit Ethernet.
Ah, geht.
Na Gigabit Ethernet, wenn du es schnell haben willst, Gigabit Ethernet ist schneller als Firewire, theoretisch, praktisch nicht. Aber praktisch ist der Unterschied nicht so groß.
Ich dachte immer, Gigabit Ethernet geht nicht über Crossover.
Klar, und außerdem brauchst du ja gar keinen Crossover-Kabel, weil die Rechner das ja von alleine umdrehen, die erkennen das ja schon seit ehemaligen Jahren.
Ja, aber zumindest die ersten Geräte mit Gigabit Ethernet konnten, also wenn du die direkt aneinandergehängt hattest, hattest du kein Gigabit Ethernet, sondern du brauchst deswegen einen Switch dazwischen. Ach echt?
Nee, ist mir neu.
Um Gigabit Ethernet tatsächlich nutzen zu können. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das mittlerweile im Griff haben.
Ist das etwas, was du glaubst oder was du sicher weißt?
Nicht sicher genug, um jetzt meine Hand für uns Feuer zu legen, aber...
Du darfst wieder den Link suchen.
Du darfst wieder den Link suchen, meines Wissens ging das schon immer. Also, als Dennis im Club, als irgendwie alle Gigabit-Laptops hatten, das ging doch auch mit normalen Kabeln. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass wir nach Crossover-Kabeln gesucht haben.
Ich hab da auch schon was Beaters gemacht mit Gigabit-Kabel. Dazwischen haben wir 60 Megabyte die Sekunde übertragen. Da war kein Switch dazwischen. Den hatten wir nämlich noch gar nicht. Und das war ganz normales Kabel.
Jaja, also das stimmt nicht. Das ging schon immer mit Crossover. Also mit Auto-Crossover.
Aber ich hoffe, das Wort Crossover-Kabel hat er auch schon seit Jahren nicht mehr gehört.
So, was ist noch neu? LED-Display im MacBook. Sicherlich keine längere Diskussion wert. Endlich! Tastatur, Hintergrundbeleuchtung hatten wir noch. Was natürlich bei MacBook Pro wunderbar ist, haben wir es schon erwähnt, dass Platte und Batterie leicht zu wechseln sind. Ja, haben wir schon erwähnt.
Haben wir schon erwähnt.
WLAN-mäßig, Luftflug-mäßig ist ja nicht... Hier reicht es mal wieder nicht. Nichts Neues dazu gekommen.
Größere Platten gibt es halt jetzt. 128 GB SSD.
Wenn man will, ja.
Wenn man will, ich sehe da noch nicht den Grund dafür. Und ich finde auch eine 320 GB Platte immer noch interessanter.
Auf jeden.
Ich sag euch, 100 GB frei. Das ist wirklich die Devise. Man muss mal 100 GB frei haben, dann ist man ein glücklicher Mensch.
Also, eine größere Festplatte will ich mir schon irgendwann noch mal demnächst mal gönnen, weil...
Kostet ja nix.
Ich hab eine 120er da drin, kostet ja nix. Und außerdem so eine blöde 120er-Platte, die ist ja wirklich immer voll. Dann gerne mit 7200 Umdrehungen, was richtig schön schnell ist und... Das ist nochmal fällig. Worüber wir jetzt noch gar nicht geredet haben, ist das MacBook Air. Da gibt es ja auch kleinere Neuigkeiten.
Ja, die haben auch den Nvidia-Stein drin ab November, ne? Glaub ich, wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe. Ja, das könnte das Gerät nach vorne bringen. Vor allem auch von 80 auf 120 GB könnte eine Menge Leute noch mal auf das Air ziehen.
Und das SSD ist auch doppelt so groß jetzt, ne? Nicht mehr 64 GB, so wie früher, also kleiner als die Platte, sondern jetzt mit 128 GB größer als die Festplatte. Und das ist dann doch schon interessant, weil niemand will downgraden mit SSD, sondern eigentlich mehr haben.
Das stimmt, genau, man hat sogar mehr für die 500 Euro extra. 500 Euro mehr, ne? Genau, 2,5. Und ja, das wird dann schon richtig interessant. Ich weiß nicht, hat das größere noch was anderes?
Das hat den neuen Chipset, das hat... Ich glaube, der Akku hält nicht mehr ganz so lange. Rein formell, beim MacBook eher. Und das ist ja das einzige Gerät, das denselben Akku hat. Das wundert mich nämlich ein bisschen.
Das liegt an dem Chipset, an der Grafikleistung.
Aber bei den MacBooks und bei den MacBook Pros, die halten ja angeblich genauso lange durch.
Die haben aber eine schwächere Akku. Genau, hat nur noch 50 Wattstunden.
Und das lässt mich noch so ein bisschen am Kopf kratzen. Wie geht das? Wieso hat das MacBook eher mit einem neuen Chipset, plötzlich bei gleichem Akku...
Weil es eine viel, viel leistungsfähige Grafikkarte hat, deswegen.
Aber das ist doch bei MacBook genauso.
Ja, bei MacBook haben sie aber auch mehr Platz, um das über Akku und sonstige Maßnahmen auszugleichen. Und bei MacBook ist halt nicht so viel Platz.
Aber der Akku ist doch auch kleiner geworden. Auch bei MacBook, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Ja, aber bei dem MacBook Pro ist es ja nur deswegen jetzt mit 5 Stunden, weil du dann auch auf der kleineren Grafikkarte da das rennen lässt, was vorher immer eine dicke war.
Stimmt, bei dem ist es relativ simpel.
Also, das will ich erstmal sehen, dass das wirklich so real weniger lange hält. Ich kann diesen ganzen Akkuangaben sowieso nicht so Glauben schenken. Das hängt so sehr davon ab, wie man das benutzt. Und von daher unklar. Ja, also das neue Air ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Kandidat, muss ich sagen. Aber ich glaube, ich will schon noch mehr Platte haben. Was dann aber wiederum fast das einzige Argument wäre. Zweiter USB-Port, Audio-Innen will ich auch haben.
Hat das eher denn jetzt auch Display-Port oder noch den Mini-DVI?
Das hat dann auch Display-Port. Also das Update. Ich denke, dass jedes Geräte-Update, was wir jetzt sehen werden, im Macintosh-Bereich mit sich bringen.
Hat er ja gesagt.
Das ist glaube ich ganz klar.
Ja.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall eine sinnvolle Ergänzung, aber ich glaube, das 17 Zoll, was sie aktualisiert haben, das hat das noch nicht.
Ist ja auch nicht aktualisiert.
Nicht wirklich.
Das wird noch aktualisiert.
Auch Nvidia-Stein mit drin.
Ach, ist der auch im 17 Zoll jetzt doch mit drin?
Zumindest die Grafik. Der Chipset ist nicht drin, aber die Grafikkarte, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Ich blätter nochmal kurz. Wir klicken live.
Das war doch schon vorher so. Eine Nvidia-Grafikkarte war doch schon vorher.
Das stimmt, das ist auch nicht die neue. Sonst nach wie vor diese 8600H mit drin.
Aber ich finde ja wirklich ganz irre, dass Apple jetzt wirklich in einem Schlag in allen mobilen Geräten, die sie so haben, in allen, was sie vorgestellt haben, neu den Chipsats-Hersteller ausgewechselt haben. Also ich meine, das deutet ja darauf hin, dass dieser Nvidia-Chipsats, der muss ja wirklich schon ganz großartig sein, dass er sowohl für einen Consumer-Einsteiger-Laptop taugt, als auch für das Pro-Gerät, als auch für das Ultramobile.
Ja, ich denke es geht hier auch einfach darum, dass sie jetzt voll auf GPU-Power setzen. Das hatten wir schon ein paar Mal das Thema mit dem OpenCL. Wenn sie mit SnowLeopard für ihre Technologien, für Quartz und was weiß ich für was noch alles, für Encoder, Decoder, OpenCL nutzen und das sozusagen dann auch voll auf die verfügbare Performance der Grafikkarte zurückgreifen können, dann würden wir da einfach einen signifikanten Speed-Up sehen.
Also das ist sozusagen deine Vorhersage für die Zukunft?
Das ist meine Vorhersage und das ist meiner Meinung nach auch einer der Gründe, warum sie da gerne auch mit Nvidia gehen. Dass es jetzt nicht nur so ist, dass sie mal angerufen haben, gesagt haben, wir haben da jetzt mal so einen Chipset, den könnt ihr ja auch mal einbauen, sondern dass das eher eine strategische Partnerschaft an der Stelle ist, weil Nvidia ist der Vorreiter bei dieser CUDA-Geschichte, bei der Programmierbarkeit von Grafikchips überhaupt, also auch schon mit ihren loadable shaders, damit hat das ja irgendwie angefangen und da haben wir da ihre eigene Programmiersprache, dieses CG entwickelt am Anfang. Das sind alles so diese Entwicklungsschritte dahin und jetzt ist es halt eben diese mit OpenCL dann auch wirklich gut nutzbare Technologie. Also das ist so das, wo das alles Sinn macht für mich.
Diese Erweiterung von diesem X264 Codec heißt übrigens Bada-Boom.
Bada-Boom.
Ja, schön fand ich ja auch diese Q&A-Session am Ende, wo noch mal ein paar kluge Fragen gestellt wurden, unter anderem zum Thema Blu-ray.
Genau.
Ihr habt die Antwort sicherlich auch mitbekommen. Fand ich großartig.
Hast du das wörtliche Zitat? Das wörtliche Zitat kennt ja leider niemand so richtig.
Doch, das kennt man. Das ist aufgeschrieben worden.
Doch, das gibt's ja als Interview irgendwo. Bag of, was war's?
It's great to watch the movies, but the licensing of the tech is so complex, we're waiting till things settle down and Blu-ray takes off in the marketplace, wurde da gesagt. Und er meinte noch, es wäre ein Bag of Hurt. Und sie hätten da einfach Lizenzprobleme.
Darf man da freundlich rauslesen, dass für Apple Blu-ray tot ist? Ich würde so weit gehen.
Der zweite Kommentar, der kam, glaube ich, von Phil Schiller noch hinterher, wo er dann meinte so, wir haben doch super HD mit iTunes.
Eben.
Das ist wahrscheinlich jetzt der strategische Move, von denen entweder Lizenzgebühren runterzukriegen, sodass es sich überhaupt erst mal für die lohnt. Und mit ihrem iTunes-HD ist sowieso, dass sie noch was ganz anderes eigentlich im Boot haben. Aber auf lange Sicht wissen die wahrscheinlich auch, dass Blu-ray wird das letzte physikalische Medium noch sein für Movies. Danach ist vorbei mit Medien. Auch einfach keiner mehr.
Das glaube ich auch.
Vielleicht ist es sogar schon, dass es schon mit der DVD vorbei war eigentlich.
Die DVD läuft doch wie Sau. Geh doch mal in eine Videotheke.
Die DVD ist das letzte Medium.
Genau, Max meint, dass DVD das letzte ist.
Blu-ray wird es eben nicht mehr so richtig schaffen. Das wird es nicht ablösen. Deswegen lohnt es sich nicht mehr, da groß einzusteigen.
Ich meine, Sie reden hier von dem Licensing. Sie reden nicht von den Licensing-Costs. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die Kosten das eigentliche Problem sind, sondern der Zwang, dass wenn du Blu-ray hast, dass du eben diese vollständige Kette mit HDCP von unten bis oben machen musst. Also Blu-ray legt extrem große Last auf deinen Systemdesign. Und das ist glaube ich etwas, was Apple einfach mal total scheiße findet. Also sie wollen sich einfach mal nicht nur, damit sie da Blu-ray einbauen können, vorschreiben lassen, was sie da drin haben. Und tatsächlich ist ja auch Displayport hat ja sein eigenes Copy-Protection-Schema drin. Also das HDCP von HDMI hat beim Displayport ein DPCP, wobei, wenn man im Wikipedia-Artikel glauben darf, nächste Versionen kann dann auch HDCP und so weiter. Also die werden sich da schon irgendwie gegenseitig rüber helfen. Wie auch immer, Blu-ray ist kein Thema für Apple und sie sehen das definitiv nicht als strategisches Produkt, sondern eher so als, naja, müssen wir vielleicht irgendwann dann doch mal unter Umständen auch noch mit anbieten, falls es irgendjemand interessiert. Aber es ist nicht mehr so wie früher, wo DVD-Authoring wirklich ein Kernmarkt war für Apple, sondern ihre Zukunft sehen sie woanders. Die Leute kaufen sich keinen Mac, damit sie damit Blu-ray, interaktive Blu-ray-Scheiben machen können.
Na und auch bei den PC-Laptops sind ja einige Hersteller mittlerweile dabei, wieder abzurüsten, die vorher Blu-ray-Geräte verkauft haben, die dann einfach jetzt das Blu-ray-Laufwerk wieder rausschmeißen, weil es niemand will, weil es zu teuer ist, weil die Leute es nicht wirklich annehmen. Also insofern ist meine weitere Vorhersage aus diesem Event für die Zukunft, Blu-ray wird es nie so richtig schaffen. Wenn Apple jetzt kein Blu-ray-Gerät vorstellt, dann werden sie es so bald auch nicht tun.
Sehe ich ähnlich so. Zweite Frage ging zum Thema Touchscreen-Displays. Kurze Antwort. So far it hasn't made a lot of sense to us. Auch wieder eine schöne zurückhaltende Formulierung, aber ist auch so nicht das erste Mal gefallen. Sie denken einfach nicht, dass ein Touchscreen-Computer, zumindest jetzt bei Laptops, ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie die Frage gestellt wurde, dass das irgendwie eine wichtige Rolle spielt.
Im Internet, im Interweb, kursiert eine schöne Anleitung, wie man sich selber ein kleines Touchscreen-Macbook bauen kann, quasi aus einem Gigabyte-Netbook. Gibt es eins, das ein Touchscreen hat, für 400 Euro oder so was, und da hat jemand Mac OS X zum Laufen aufgebracht. Sieht echt ganz hübsch aus, mit Fingern zu bedienen und mit Stift, aber sieht auch nicht so aus, als ob man sie jeden Tag machen möchte.
Und eine dritte Frage ging zum Thema Netbook oder Low-Cost-Laptop. Und da meinte er nur, a nascent market that's just getting started.
Wo sie ja auch recht haben.
Zumal dieser Netbook-Markt auch derzeit meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen over halbt ist.
Warte mal, was hab ich da gerade vorhin gelesen bei Golem? Für wie viel Prozent Anteile der schon zuständig ist? Warte mal, jetzt muss ich mal her. Oder ihr könnt euch ja über was anderes unterhalten, ich suche so lange mal raus, wie die Marktanteile sind. Ich glaube, es waren 10 Prozent des Marktanteils. Genau. Netbooks schnappen sich 10 Prozent vom PC-Markt in Europa.
Ich wollte mich gerade kurz mal auf Klo schleichen, dann sagst du ihr, ihr könnt das unterhalten.
Jetzt hab ich es ja rausgesucht, 10 Prozent.
Das ist wieder diese alte Marktanteil-Geschichte. Ich halte da jetzt nicht so viel, weil was mich mal sehr viel mehr interessieren würde, ist, was ist der Dollar-Marktanteil von den Netbooks? Weil was wird denn mit diesen Geräten tatsächlich verdient? Die Teile werden für 300, 400 Dollar verkauft. Ich schätze mal, bei der Konkurrenzsituation dürfte die Marge nicht gerade besonders üppig sein. Viel Geld verdienen kann man damit, glaube ich, nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Hauptgrund, warum Apple das derzeit auch noch nicht als einen interessanten Markt ansieht. Abgesehen von Usability-Problematiken, die so kleine Geräte mit sich bringen.
Und ich vermute mal einfach, dass es, also Usability-Probleme auf der einen Seite, aber auf der anderen Seite ist ja die Performance bei den Dingern wirklich nicht so doll, wie man es von einem Apple-Gerät erwartet. Weil so ein kleines MacBook, muss man ja mal sagen, noch langsamer sollte es ja auch nicht unbedingt sein. Und diese Atom-Dinger sind halt wirklich noch mal deutlich langsamer als so ein kleines MacBook.
Ja, und ich denke auch, dass die Leute nicht bereit sind, beliebig kleinen Bildschirm zu akzeptieren. Also, meine ich, hier diesen Asus IPC, den ich dir abgekauft habe, das hat sich ja hier bei BlinkenLights als ein sehr hilfreiches Gerät herausgestellt.
Aber für den täglichen Einsatz auch komplett unbrauchbar.
Absolut. Das ist eine schöne Fummelkiste, wo man so Custom Setup und noch ein paar Skrips draufballern und so, da konnten wir hier schön unsere Geräte mitflaschen. Dafür war das irgendwie alles prima und war auch schön klein zum Rumtragen, wenn man durch die Gegend geht. Aber am Ende ist das einfach kein Gerät, mit dem ich irgendwas machen wollen würde. Und nochmal zu dem Marktanteil, das kam ja bei dieser Präsentation auch nochmal sehr schön zur Sprache. Bei Laptops, fasse ich das jetzt richtig zusammen, bei Laptops ist jeder dritte Dollar, der ausgegeben wird in den USA, wohlgemerkt, geht an Apple. Also 30% im Retail-Markt. Der Retail-Markt ist für sie ja sehr wichtig, weil das eben der Konsumermarkt ist vor allem. Da ist es jetzt ein bisschen schwierig zu bewerten, welchen Anteil Online-Verkäufe hat bei Laptops. Von daher ist das auch eine wackelige Zahl. Aber dass halt Apples Dollar-Marktanteil sehr viel höher ist als dieser Stückzahl-Marktanteil, der immer gerne bemüht wird. Das ist ja wichtig, weil Apple verdient einfach mehr Geld in diesem Segment.
Retail ist in dem Segment extrem wichtig, weil Dell damit komplett raus ist.
Ja, aber ich glaube, sie fragten... Dell hat gar keine Läden, ne? Doch, Dell hat sicherlich Rechner über Läden, oder nicht?
Nee, ich weiß nicht, ob sie mittlerweile mit angefangen haben, die wollten damit anfangen, aber Dell konntest du immer nur über Mail-Oder bestellen. Historisch.
Ja gut, aber von daher wäre natürlich so eine Statistik auch nochmal interessant. So oder so ist klar, Apple verdient mehr Geld mit einem verkauften Gerät als jemand anders. Und ihr Marktanteil bei, was war das, über 1000 Dollar im Retailmarkt in den USA liegt schon irgendwie bei 66 Prozent. Also irgendwie zwei Drittel aller Geräte über 1000 Dollar sind Macs. Das ist schon enorm. Und ich denke auch, dass die nächsten Quartalsergebnisse, wann stehen die an? Das ist nicht mehr so lange hin, ne? Wird wahrscheinlich wieder ein... Nächste Woche. Nächste Woche. Da haben wir schon mal einen Grund, wieder eine Sendung vorzuziehen. Können wir uns mal über Finanzen unterhalten. Also mal richtig kompetent.
Ja, das ist doch mal hey! Eine Woche später erklären wir die Finanzmarktkrise. Das wird ein Spaß. Ich glaube, die Zahlen sind von Apple auch immer schön gerechnet. Da dieses Retail-Argument mit reinzupacken. Ich glaube, Apples Marktanteil ist definitiv am Steigen. Ich glaube, dass die neuen MacBooks wirklich noch mal richtig was dazu beitragen werden. Das sind ja wirklich, wie ich finde, unglaublich schöne Geräte. Aber ich glaube, überwertend, ganz so doll, wie es laut Apple rüberkommt, ist es dann doch nicht. Wenn ich zugeben muss, dass wenn man hier in ein Café geht und sich da mal anguckt, wie viele Leute haben da einen PC und wie viele haben Mac, dass man schon eher das Gefühl hätte, dass Apple einen Marktanteil von 90 Prozent hätte. Egal, wie man rechnet.
Ja, also das ist auf jeden Fall alles noch nicht am Ende. Aber vielleicht sollten wir langsam zum Ende kommen. Was für eine tolle Überleitung. Vielleicht sollten wir nochmal kurz in die Kommentare gucken, hier zu unserem Posting auf dem Mobile Max mit Fragen.
Habt ihr denn auch mitbekommen, dass diese iPhone Tech Talk ist irgendwann Anfang November?
Hab ich mitbekommen.
Ja, in Berlin, genau.
Ich hab mich angemeldet.
Als Creator Developer, genau. Ich hab mich auch angemeldet, aber noch keine Bestätigung bekommen. Und ich hab mich angemeldet, als Berlin noch nicht voll war. Ich weiß nicht, ob es inzwischen schon voll ist.
Ah, warte mal, dann mach ich das jetzt nochmal rasch. Weil ich hab mich nämlich noch nicht angemeldet.
Und ganz viele Twitterer oder Follower haben auch schon gesagt, dass sie da hinkommen. Sogar Antenne will kommen.
Dass sie programmieren lernen?
Ja, sie will Quartz-Composing-Schnick-Schnack machen. Was gar nicht geht auf dem iPhone, wie der letzte Mal berichtet hat. Trotzdem anmelden, falls Leute abspringen.
Tja, Max, wir erzählen, wie es war. Aber ich weiß ja noch gar nicht, ob wir angenommen werden. Bestätigung haben wir noch nicht bekommen. Ja, so. Fragen. Hier gibt es Fragen. Wo kauft ihr im Web und in Berlin eure Mac-Hardware? Und, ihr so?
Ich hab die immer beim Fuchs gekauft, um ein bisschen Werbung zu machen.
Aber das ist schon eine Weile her.
Weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt immer noch kaufen würde.
Ich kauf immer noch beim Fuchs. Beim Fuchs, machen wir ein bisschen Werbung machen für den Fuchs. Ich glaub, für den Fuchs kann man ordentlich Werbung machen. Fuchs Data in Berlin ist so eine kleine Bude. Eine der wenigen Läden, die halt sowohl Macintosh als auch PC-Kompetenz besitzen. Was immer sehr schön ist, weil man da einfach immer ordentliche Antworten bekommt.
Und die können auch löten. Die haben mir mal mein iPod gerettet. Mein iPod der vierten Generation, der wollte einfach nicht mehr, der ist mir runtergefallen und ging nicht mehr. Und dann hat der mir für 20 Euro ein neues Kabel eingebaut und danach lief er immerhin noch ein halbes Jahr. Wobei man von vornherein gesagt hat, dass er wahrscheinlich nicht so ewig laufen wird. Insofern war das damals ein extrem fern Deal. In der Kassanianlee sitzen die. In der Kassanianlee in Prenzlberg. Aber ansonsten kaufe ich ehrlich gesagt relativ pragmatisch immer da, wo es gerade geht. Was ein Freund von mir festgestellt hat, dass man bei Galeria Kaufhof kriegt man ganz unglaublich günstige Finanzierung für MacBooks und für Apple-Produkte.
Finanzierung.
Machen wir eine nächste Sendung.
Auf Kredit. Wenn man auf Kredit kauft, zahlt man da keine Zinsen.
Wir müssen wirklich eine Finanzsendung machen, oder? Wir lernen jetzt einfach alle mal Finanzmarkt und geben unser Halbwissen Preis. Gut, also wir haben jetzt zwar noch zwei, drei nicht-Macintosh-Themen hier mal notiert, aber ich würde die ganz gerne auf die nächste Sendung schieben, weil wir hier gerade noch fleißig sind und ich nicht so viel Zeit hab.
Und die nächste Sendung machen wir dann wieder auch face-to-face, ne?
Die nächste Sendung machen wir face-to-face. Wir können ja mal überlegen, ob wir unseren Senderhythmus erhöhen können. Vielleicht können wir ja face-to-face und Skype irgendwie abwechseln, wäre ja auch eine Variante. Mal schauen. Ja, noch letzte Worte von irgendjemand?
Toller. Ich will ein neues MacBook. Was soll sonst das Wort sein?
Neues MacBook Pro.
Schauen wir mal, wer bis zur nächsten Sendung sich was gekauft hat.
Schöne Grüße noch nach Toronto.
Ja.
Und bis in zwei Wochen in Berlin, oder?
Ich bin nächste Woche wieder da.
Großartig.
Also, wenn das Flugzeug hält, was es verspricht.
Wem ich fliegt?
Fliegt zum Beispiel, genau.
Dahin fliegt, wo es soll und all das.
Nicht so viel mit Tech-Gadgets rumspielen an Bord, das bringt beim Flugzeug immer zum Abstürzen. Telefon anlässt oder so was, oder eine Kamera anschaltet oder ein Laptop oder weissetwas.
Jaja, Riesenprobleme, man hört täglich davon. Okay, Schluss mit dem ganzen Blabla. Alles klar, bis demnächst.
Tschüss.